what's going on guys this is Rob and God
the ending of this is probably going to
be one of the most important things that
I think Marvel has been doing recently
in Marvel Comics so much so that like we
literally just kind of have to cover
this as a One-Shot origin so this takes
place in Immortal X-Men and it basically
builds and expands on the origin of Mr
Sinister from Marvel Comics going into
the sins of sinister's storyline which
will basically make the whole thing make
more sense so what this does here is
this initially opens up with Mystique
basically making her way into a military
base in New Mexico in 1943. now one of
the things to understand here and this
is what's really cool is that actually
makes her way through of course using
her powers and so on and so forth so
doing the different soldiers and so on
she ends up coming across Irene Adler
now one of the things to know is that
Irene Adler of course the mutant Destiny
she's a precog for those of you guys who
are not familiar with Irene Adler if you
know who she is bear with me here for a
second Destiny is a precognitive where
she can basically see the future the
further away she looks or the further
into the future she she looks the less
certain things are the closer she looks
into the future the more certain things
are but the thing that's going on here
and the reason why Irene Adler's even
here in the first place and Mystique is
meeting up with her is because this is a
laboratory or basically a facility where
Mr Sinister is working now one of the
things that I want to specify here is
that Sinister is a character with an
exceedingly long history in Marvel and
we'll talk about the existing origin for
his character as we get further into
this specifically the story from 1996
The Adventures of Cyclops and Gene but
the reason why this matters in terms of
it being in 1943 is because this is
where Sinister was operating at the time
that one of the things that Sinister had
done over the course of his existence is
he had become obsessed with the idea
that individuals were popping up around
the world that had powers right
basically mutants and so one of the
things that he had done during World War
II is he had experimented on people in
German camps the reason why that matters
is because following the end of the war
and the liberation of all those camps a
guy named true at Hudson had discovered
the journals of sinister and that's what
led to weapons plus right that's what
led to like Wolverine and Phantom X and
the stuff for cacus and all those guys
right so a little cool bit of history
there when it comes to how the weapons
plus and weapons 2 through 10 programs
came into existence weapon one is
Captain America that actually was not
based on the works of sinister uh at
least not that I'm aware of because I
feel like the discovery of Truett Hudson
happened after Captain America was
frozen in ice so I don't know it's
Marvel doesn't really reconcile that too
well but the thing that Irene Adler says
and while her and and I'm sorry her and
Mystique have a very lengthy history
together Irene Adler says she's here and
she's quote unquote assisting Sinister
in experimenting on mutants because the
end result right the ends justify the
means like yes there's some pretty shady
stuff going on here right now but at the
end of the day what can be learned from
this and the greater consequence of what
Sinister is doing is more important than
the lives of the people who are being
sacrificed here at the moment and that's
one of those moral things that really
plays under the nature of Destiny to me
oftentimes she'll let people be
sacrificed in the moment if it goes
towards something more important now a
person who can't see the future of
course cannot necessarily see the bigger
picture and the average person operates
in the Here and Now not being able to
see or even understand what role they
play in a greater landscape So to that
person being experimented on it's
begging the question why isn't anybody
helping me whereas Destiny looks at that
and says because quite literally your
life in the moment is basically
meaningless and your sacrifice here will
go to a much bigger thing but from here
there's really kind of a discussion
between the two of them in terms of
asking the question how did Sinister
survive his first first death in the
first place and so what we do is we jump
back to 1895 in London England and this
is when we really start to get into the
nature of sinister's origin though what
we actually end up having here in a
really really cool moment is we pick up
a 221 Baker Street or 221B Baker Street
anybody who knows anything about that
address knows that's the address of
Sherlock Holmes
now one of the funny things about this
and I love that Marvel's doing this
Sherlock Holmes does exist in Marvel
Comics he was in the old Marvel preview
issue number five back in 1976. he was
there for like one story nobody really
cared ultimately Marvel just kind of
Acts the existence of the character I
love that they're doing that by
basically saying it was Mystique
operating as as basically Sherlock
Holmes pretending to be him whether or
not it was like there is an actual
Sherlock Holmes and Mystique was
impersonating him or Marvel's simply
just saying there never was a Sherlock
Holmes and it's just an identity that
that Mystique is taking is really just
kind of you know up to interpretation to
be quite honest because even now they
don't necessarily clarify it too well
but what's cool is that the two of them
basically end up meeting up in order to
travel to milberry house which is where
Sinister is operating out of at the
moment and in fact when they get there
they don't really meet Sinister they
meet Nathaniel Essex now here's the cool
thing about this and this is when we
really start to get into this origin
because what ends up happening here is
mystique and death Destiny have this
conversation with Essex where he says my
work on the Essex factors would be much
more advanced if I could be returned to
the years I wasted on fripperies like
love Nathaniel Essex wife died at some
point and so he really like looks back
on his life and says instead of getting
involved in things like love I could
have been working on my research right
like love prevented me from becoming
successful and focusing on more
important things as far as he's
concerned don't know I entirely agree
but nonetheless right what's really cool
here is that Irene Adler chimes in and
says Lord Darwin right this is the time
when Charles Darwin was still like the
top guy in the scientific Community she
says that that according to Darwin The
Works of sinister were basically a
monstrous misunderstanding of Darwin's
work himself and she fears that
basically she has to agree here that she
asked have you ever read Nietzsche your
talk of superior beings Echoes him his
work also ended in Madness it is not too
late to turn back now here's the reason
why this discussion matters here and
this is how we basically start to get
into the origin of sinister in the early
days of Nathaniel Essex when he was in
the scientific community and he was
obsessed with the idea that basically
mutants were popping up what he's
referring to as the Essex factor is the
x-gene inside of mutants that has not
been activated yet right remember the X
Gene and mutants activates either
through puberty or moments of high
duress or something like that but in
having no real name called The X Factor
he simply refers to it as the Essex
Factor he names it after himself is
really all it is but there came a point
when he created this really kind of
frankensteinian depiction of what those
individuals out there who are basically
mutants and half Powers would look like
he built his work on the work of Charles
Darwin and saying that Charles Darwin
argues that Evolution Reigns Supreme
that individual organisms right birds
and bugs and animals and so on and so
forth that they all exist in these
different environments and ecosystems
and over time those environments and
ecosystems will change and that
Evolution will take hold of those
animals and they will evolve to
basically adapt in in that environment
what got him cast out of the scientific
Community was his depiction of the Essex
Gene and his depiction of what a future
mutant might look like which was
honestly very grotesque to the
scientific community at the time they
considered him to be a madman and they
ultimately forced him out and that's
where he that's why he's here now
because he's kind of an outcast of the
scientific community and is driven by
this desire to prove that he was right
and so the cool thing about this is that
them meeting with him really comes down
to this discussion that like he was
attacked by somebody he can't really
provide any details about it he didn't
really see what happened he just knows
that like he woke up and and somehow he
survived and you know he believes that
it was one of those meetings that exist
out there but following this this leads
to a kind of I guess detective a bit of
detective work by Mystique where she
takes on the guise of an innocent young
woman and starts making her way through
the city of London when she hears
somebody scream and when she gets there
she finds Sinister killing a guy and so
that's when literally she fires a shot
at him he realizes she can shapeshift so
she basically her existence verifies
that he's right that there are people
out there with powers right although it
was already kind of verified up to this
point he ultimately takes to the
rooftops and then runs back to his base
of operations when Irene Adler when
Destiny and Mystique catch up to him
they find him transforming from Sinister
back into Essex and that's when he comes
clean with the explanation now one of
the things to understand this is where
we kind of get really more broadly into
this origin really the finer details of
this origin in Marvel Comics Sinister of
course Nathaniel Essex his obsession
with the mutant Gene the idea that there
were beings out there who have
incredible levels of power that was
eventually noticed by the villain
apocalypse right in Sabah newer that's
who he's talking about when he refers to
as the Egyptian who visited him and
granted him Powers the idea of sinister
a really Nathaniel Essex meeting
apocalypse and explaining apocalypse his
belief system that those individuals
with powers are basically the next step
in human evolution that was something
apocalypse had never considered before
all apocalypse knew was that he was just
a being with incredible power and used
that to effectively Force societies
against each other he had followed the
old social darwinist philosophy that was
instilled in him by ball and the sand
Riders which is only the strong deserve
to survive but when he met Sinister and
sinister's argument was there are people
out there with incredible power they can
do incredible things and they will lead
the world into arguably a better future
maybe not necessarily better but a
different future that apocalypse kind of
took that to heart and was like so
that's why I have the powers that I have
he almost saw it as a kind of like a
divine intervention right a Divine
Purpose for himself and this almost
religious zealotry merged with his
Viewpoint of survival of the fittest and
that's how we ended up with the version
of Apocalypse that we have today in
Marvel Comics but in order to ensure
because Nathaniel wanted to literally
spend all of time being able to explore
these genes and so on that apocalypse
basically told Nathaniel Essex he would
give him the means to do so now the
reality here is is that when apocalypse
shows up to you and says you know I can
give you a great gift it's like being
met by like like Pinhead in the
Hellraiser Universe right like the
cinebites like I mean sure right there
they have sites to show you and they can
take you to a new place of pleasure that
you could never imagine but it's a dark
and twisted version right it's literally
just pain and torment and so because of
that it's one of those things where the
gifts quote unquote of Apocalypse
oftentimes prove to be more of a curse
than anything else and so what you're
seeing here right now in terms of
Nathaniel Essex having this almost kind
of Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde's situation
where the Mr Sinister Persona is like
the evil one and Nathaniel Essex is the
good one it's basically the
quote-unquote gift of Apocalypse or him
gaining these Powers really overriding
him but what he's readily admitting here
is that the Sinister Persona is taking
hold he's moving beyond his ability to
control this version of himself that at
times going to come when something's
going to happen and ultimately the
Sinister Persona is going to completely
and totally take hold more so than that
he literally argues that just by being a
scientist and being able to just look to
the Future and see what direction things
are going in these individuals popping
up right what he calls the Essex men or
basically mutants is really what that
means that where they're popping up you
know kind of here and there and it's a
smattering of appearances that by
whatever Manner and whatever means the
number of mutants in the world will
increase and what that's going to do is
set humanity and the mutant population
on a collision course they're going to
go to war with each other if for no
other reason than the fact that the rise
in mutants will represent the
elimination of humans and so what he
talks about is how he wants to survive
and see all of that but at the end of
the day it seems like it'll be
impossible that he's toying with the
idea that he will inevitably die and for
you know perhaps even take his own life
because of the fact that he doesn't want
to become Sinister and so what he says
is he set in motion a way to guarantee
his existence but because of the level
of insanity that he's putting out there
and because of the fact that according
to Destiny he represents a clear and
present danger that what ends up
happening is he's literally locked in an
insane asylum but where he starts
babbling on and he literally starts
saying like red and black and red and
black and just kind of talking to
himself constantly seeing a person
that's not there he refers to them as a
ghost and then he's ultimately destroyed
like he literally dies in the middle of
the night and so we're like Irene I'm
sorry we're a Mystique pretending to be
Sherlock Holmes shows up here bribes a
guard and then realizes the guard is
corrupt killing them you know so that
there's no witnesses to anything in any
story they can be they can imagine can
be concocted here that what happens is
Irene Adler goes back to the to Mulberry
House and literally explores the
residents of Nathaniel Essex but she
puts on what is basically a recording of
Nathanael where he talks about these
different things and so he says Darwin
said I was wrong but I was never so
proud as to say the same to him his
Insight was profound this is what my
legacy will be this is how I will be
immortal and to see how the world will
play out this is how we'll win the war
against humanity when they try to
destroy the mutant population Charles
Darwin was right in the end there is
only one way to find a solution to my
predicament survival of the fittest and
so what we end up finding out here is
that there are four canisters down in
the basement of sinister and what he had
done is he had cloned himself four times
then each one basically has a playing
card on his head this is why this is so
important because in Jerry Dugan's X-Men
Volume 2 the stasis storyline we saw a
version of sinister that had a clover on
his head he didn't have a diamond and so
that version was literally like I
haven't like I'm the only Sinister I've
always been Sinister I don't know what
other version of sinister you're talking
about there's also one with a spade
there's one with a heart and there's one
with a diamond and so what this means
and what model is telling us is every
instance where we've seen Mr Sinister in
Marvel from this point in time in 1895
running all the way up until now it's
only been one of the four sinisters
there have been four others out there
they are three others out there and
they've just been doing their thing
we've never seen them or seemingly never
seen them and they don't know about each
other or if they do they're certainly
not revealing it but like none of like
all of them believes they're the actual
Sinister so if they did happen to come
across another or if they became aware
of another they would consider to be
some inferior clone and would probably
disregarded they wouldn't really care
about it at all but basically it's
amazing because no version of sinister
that we've seen up to this point is the
actual Nathaniel Essex that guy's been
dead for a couple hundred years he's
been gone for a long time and all we've
seen are clones running around
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the sins of sinister now
here's the thing to understand the sons
of sinister is a crossover event it is
nine issues long the first three issues
are year 10 the second three is year 100
and the final three is a year one
thousand now it doesn't really tie into
any existing X-Men Comics meaning it's
not sins of sinister X-Men number
whatever however we need to get caught
up on the X-Men so after we're done with
this we're gonna get caught back up
which is what we should have been doing
this whole time because I love the X-Men
but you can understand this without
knowing everything that's going on so
the first thing that happens here is
basically Sinister is dragged to the pit
of krakowa literally taken prisoner and
locked away now we don't need to know
everything that's going on in order to
understand the rest of this story
because honestly this is the least
interesting thing that happens this
story gets nuts but we will make sense
of why this happens once we go back and
start covering the various X-Men titles
and getting caught up one of the big
takeaways from all this is that after
this is done when you have Charles
Xavier basically him removing his helmet
you end up finding out that he's got a
Sinister diamond on his head now what
this is designed to do is to basically
illustrate the idea that Xavier himself
is under the influence of sinister but
it's not even just Professor Xavier Emma
Frost Exodus hopes Summers they're all
under the influence of sinister so we
don't know exactly how he did this we
will find out in this story but we don't
know exactly how he did this here in the
moment the bigger discussion that goes
on here is the question of what do they
do now that the seeds there's so many
seeds in the quiet Council are empty
right the ruling governing body of the
X-Men on the mutant island of krakowa
now some of the things that led to this
we have already covered so when you had
like The Inferno event where it turned
out that Maury McTaggart the one who
would set all this up in the first place
that she had put together the plan of
krakowa and giving mutants a safe haven
because what she wanted to do and having
died and lived a new life so many times
she literally always saw that no matter
what happened there was always a war
between humans and mutants or humans and
like some alien race or something like
that but the mutant population was
always wiped out no matter what happened
mutants were always destroyed and so her
idea was that in order to keep that from
happening by having the quiet Council
and the resurrection protocols and all
that kind of stuff over time as
different X-Men were resurrected they'd
be resurrected without their powers and
that would lead to them being forced out
of krakowa and over time it would reduce
the number of mutants that exist in the
world hence the reason why krakawa was
presented as a safe haven for the
entirety of the mutant population
because it was a really simple and
elegant way for Mora to effectively
genetically remove mutants or at least
genetically remove the mutant Gene from
the human population therefore
preventing the end-all destruction of
the mutant population so it was pretty
wild and depending on where you stand
morally you may or may not agree with it
but of course at the end of that story
there were a few things going on one
Sinister of course is currently part of
The Quiet counselor was until he was
taken way and again we'll get caught up
on why that happened but with the events
of Inferno and Maura McTaggart that
Destiny the mutant precognitive the one
who can basically predict the future she
and Mystique who of course have been
long time lovers in Marvel Comics they
left right so a lot of these seats are
empty here so the discussion that's
being asked by Professor Xavier and Emma
Frost and these guys is why don't we
fill these seats with humans now for the
most part this is almost completely and
totally shut down by Exodus but he ends
up changing his mind once Hope Summers
agrees with it now this is not like
Exodus being a simp right I know some
people may have like that knee-jerk
reaction see without having any evidence
about the character whatsoever or
knowing nothing about his motivations
I've drawn a complete and total
unquestionable conclusion uh the reality
when it comes to Exodus if you've been
reading the X-Men for a while is that
he's not in love with hope the idea here
is that he sees hope as basically the
Messiah a god-like being and rightfully
so right it was with the birth of Hope
Summers in Marvel Comics that the X-Men
or really mutants started to return to
Marvel Comics after the events of House
of M and decimation when the Scarlet
Witch took away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers right effectively
wiped out most of the mutant population
and so when this is initially thrown out
there for the most part the quiet
household actually starts to agree with
it and the reason why is because what
they want to do is they want to
basically impose this way of Conquering
the world now we'll see how this unfolds
over the course of this because I'll be
honest with you guys it's a genius
strategy and it's a genius plan because
what they do here is by bringing human
beings onto the quiet Council one that
begins to quell the concern of different
governments out there about what the
mutants are up to by giving them a peek
on the inside of the island of kakawa
and in fact allowing them a seat on the
governing body it gives human beings the
illusion of control and so what we do is
we jump forward one year and we have
reporter Ben Urich meeting with Jay
Jonah Jameson from the Spider-Man comics
at The Daily Bugle now the funny thing
here is that Ben Uric is being
incredibly careful here right
exceedingly cautious and the reason for
this is that as he meets with Jay Jonah
Jameson he injects him with a kind of
chemical and what this does is it's
basically designed to see who is
infected with the X Gene that's
circulating around out there and who's
not and so what ends up happening is
that once it turns out that Jay Jonah
Jameson is seemingly his normal self
then York spills the beans on everything
that he's discovered and what he learned
is that when human beings were brought
onto the Kawaii Council that what the
mutant population started doing was
handing out these different genes right
that could prolong life different things
like that kind of an upgraded version so
to speak of the different medicines and
stuff that cocoa had but what it
secretly did is it planted a gene inside
of the of human beings that would allow
them at any point in time to be
overtaken by the mutant population it's
a trojan horse and so when that happened
what you started seeing was that people
who were their normal selves but had the
gene would suddenly switch right a
switch would would kind of flick in
their head and they would become
basically an agent of the mutant
population really by extension an agent
of sinister sort of doing their own
thing or doing whatever it is they were
told to do and so that's literally when
Ben yurich's like I mean I've spotted
that with a few people here and there
but I mean what if it's like politicians
right senators and congressmen
congresswomen right what do we do in
that kind of situation right some
dictator out there somewhere right
people who run entire countries could be
compromised and under control of the
mutant population and that's what we end
up finding out that Jay Jonah Jameson is
under control with the Sinister Gene
that the idea here is that the test that
was used by Ben Uric was a false test
that was leaked out there so that people
who were by and large looking at this as
a kind of Nefarious act would leap on
that opportunity to expose the truth to
the world it's a very very smart move
right just basically throw out a reel
add a little bit of bait and then bring
them in and then have them taken over by
the Gene and that's what happens with
Ben yurich it is to a degree if we're
being honest the plot to the film
um oh my God what is that movie with the
Invasion of the Body Snatchers that's
basically what this is to a degree and
so the bigger concern that they have
here is okay what do we do about the
mutant nation of kokoro right the living
Island what do we do about this right I
mean this is literally a living Island
that can at any point in time make the
entire environment inhospitable to us
right it can just start filling the air
with some kind of a toxic gas that can
kill us right it's like M Night
shyamalan's the happening right where
plants are killing people like that's
basically the concern they have so Forge
ends up inventing or creating this
cannon that can be fired from the from a
satellite that will basically lobotomize
uh krakowa and that's exactly what
happens they fire this cannon they take
out the mutant island of krakowa and
that's when the X-Men make their move
that Emma Frost telepathically
broadcasts to the world because one of
the things that the X-Men is sort of
built on is by saying by having this
Gene right telling Humanity if you have
this Gene that means we can back up you
and your loved one this also comes out
of the events of Judgment Day right
that's when Humanity learned that the
X-Men had like the resurrection
protocols people were pissed off because
the X-Men basically had the ability to
bring the dead back to life with all
their memories and Humanity wanted that
that's what that's what the X-Men are
building on here and so that's when Emma
Frost broadcasts to the world she says
the orcas space station right this group
that's been out there since the
beginning of Jonathan Hickman's run that
has been working against the meeting
population for a while think of them as
like the modern day interpretation of
like Friends of Humanity or like the
right or something like that right like
the purifiers to a degree but they
literally say like the orcas space
station has laid an attack against
krakowa and by attacking our Island
they've destroyed not only the backups
for us as X-Men but the backups for all
your human loved ones so we need to
strike back against the orcas station
literally they fabricate an attack and
use that as a as really a an excuse to
wipe out their own enemy by having
everybody else come under this false
pretense and so literally what happens
here of course also Douglas Ramsey's
killed by Wolverine because Douglas
Ramsey can kind of figure out what's
going on right he's the one that talks
to the mutant island of krakowa but what
ends up happening here is under the
false pretense that orcas led the attack
that during this one year time Jump the
X-Men bring together the Avengers and a
whole host of other superheroes and
launch an attack against orcas now the
one thing that could stand in their way
and the one thing that could annihilate
all of them is Nimrod right the ultimate
Sentinel the machine that had the
ability to recognize their powers and
adapt to those Powers as well as use
their weaknesses so Tony Stark ends up
developing a virus so really along with
Reed Richards and Forge end up
developing a virus that infiltrates
Nimrod and takes Nimrod offline so he's
no longer part of the equation but all
of these guys are doing it under false
pretenses the X-Men are the only ones
who are aware of what's going on that
whole whole thing with like Ben Urich
and Jay Jonah Jameson it's all super
Hush Hush at the moment right nobody
really understands or realizes the X-Men
are slowly starting to take over the
world and so in this meeting or in the
aftermath of this battle where you have
Cyclops talking to Captain America
Cyclops literally says cap it's awesome
to fight by you again right like you've
earned yourself a place as an honorary
X-Man which in this time and this in
this landscape when the X-Men are so
kind of cut off from the world that's a
huge honor well I just like being made
an honorary member of The Avengers like
40 years ago in Marvel Comics it's a big
deal and so Captain America of course
accepts the invitation Captain America
comes under the control of the X-Men and
so what ends up happening here is that
following all of this that Sinister is
brought back from the pits and now
Sinister is effectively sort of running
the show to a degree or at least kind of
enjoying everything that they're doing
what Sinister does is that while the
Kauai council is continuing their
campaign of essentially trying to take
over the world by infiltrating people
and turning them into what are basically
mind-controlled people Sinister ends up
going to his own private lab and what he
does in talking to the lab is he says
with everything going the way that that
it is give me a projection on how things
are going to play out right give me a
projection on what the future of the
world is going to look like because of
all of this and this is when things get
really really cool so one of the first
things that happens is we end up
learning that Thanos will inevitably
launch another attack against Earth and
that he's actually just sort of
traveling through the time stream and so
what ends up happening is the Juggernaut
is shrunk down to a miniature size and
then Hope Summers borrows the powers of
domino which is important because Domino
has the ability to bend luck to her side
and so Hope Summers using basically the
ability to manipulate luck fires
Juggernaut from a cannon and because
once the Juggernaut starts moving he
cannot be stopped the Juggernaut
literally punches a hole through Thanos
and kills Thanos as he's moving through
the time stream now eventually
Juggernaut re-enters into the main
Universe After exiting the time stream
but is just continuing to fly out there
in a direction and nobody ever makes an
effort to go and get him so he's just
essentially flying towards the edge of
the universe where he'll ultimately be
just destroyed following that Dr Doom
ends up figuring out what's going on
with the mutant population taking over
the world through mind control and he
ends up allying himself with name or the
Submariner because Neymar of course is
spewing a bunch of a bunch of
anti-mutant rhetoric what Victor Von
Doom doesn't know is that name of the
Submariner has been converted as well
and then it was all a ruse to get Victor
Von Doom on his side when that happens
he kills Dr Doom secretly right just
stabbing him with a trident and then
following that the Eternal start to
realize what's happening and so because
of the events at the end of Judgment Day
the peace treaty that was struck between
the X-Men and the eternals at the end of
the Judgment Day story is that the X-Men
would have control of Uranus right the
once ancient Eternal that was nigh
Unstoppable and was Unleashed during
that event and wiped out a huge portion
of the mutant population with Uranus
under their control in the Eternal X-Men
War the X-Men from basically all over
the place end up unleashing Uranus who
wipes out the entirety of the of the
Eternal now because the eternals
themselves can be resurrected in order
to prevent that from happening the
eternals are put in stasis and launched
into deep space so now they're no longer
part of the equation following that the
X-Men's attention turns to the Fantastic
Four and the concern is that because
Reed Richards is so intelligent if he
hasn't figured out what's going on right
now he inevitably will given his level
of intelligence he would have figured
this out pretty quickly but one of the
things to remember about Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four is he's very
rarely ever concerned about what goes on
with Earth because you have so many
superhero groups that are there so if
there is some kind of a major threat the
Fantastic Four will get involved but in
Marvel Comics in terms of Fantastic Four
stories that have been published for the
longest time they've been the
space-faring Multiverse exploring team
right that's kind of their Frontier
that's where they focus on things
because dealing with Earth is Small Time
stuff they've done that dance they've
done their dirt they've served their
time
and so what ends up happening here is
realizing that the different members of
the Fantastic Four all have their
strengths and weaknesses Ben Grimm is
the one who's the most easily overtaken
by the X-Men and he is it allows him to
revert to his human form and then in
turn the the Fantastic Four are kind of
sent on a false Mission by the X-Men and
by Ben Grimm and during that mission the
X-Men actually helped Ben Grim to devise
a scheme whereby the other members of
the Fantastic Four are all turned into
Ben Grimm's he in turn strangles them
all to death and that's the end of them
and so following that with Captain
America under control of the X-Men he in
turn strikes at the White House takes
out the president and then what the
X-Men do is they attack The Avengers
because at this point all the Avengers
have all been taken over so with the
Avengers launching an attack against the
US government the X-Men step in they
defeat the Avengers and they're hailed
as Heroes that's the beauty of this is
literally they kept pushing the Avengers
to do these more and more extreme tasks
so by the time time they launched an
attack against the White House the
general population who hadn't been taken
over and wasn't aware that this takeover
was happening would kind of be like yeah
I guess it was only a matter of time
before the Avengers did something crazy
like that thank God the X-Men saved us
that's the idea that's the motivation so
the X-Men are hailed as Heroes of the
world now the cool thing here is we jump
forward five years right we pick up in
year five everything we've talked about
so far is in is within one year it's a
one-year span right one year into the
future so five years into the future
storm arrives and storm of course is the
leader of the Iraqi they have the whole
they have their whole history and
everything but basically they are a
massive group of mutants that we didn't
know existed until Jonathan Hickman
started writing the X-Men they initially
existed in another dimension but once
they ended up arriving in the main
Marvel Universe they took up residence
on Mars and they formed their own
government storm eventually became the
leader of that Circle right that's what
they call their governing body on uh on
Mars and it's just kind of been
operating as their leader ever since but
with with all of this happening storm is
watching everything taking place and
she's realizing how extreme the X-Men
are becoming and the kind of battles
they're getting into and she's not
trusting them more so than that what she
realizes is that the Nightcrawler that's
currently there is not the actual
Nightcrawler he's an impersonator and so
when she asks the question where is the
real Nightcrawler that's when Sinister
presents himself now one thing to know
is that storm was not on the quantity or
at least was on the quiet Council when
Sinister was locked away but she didn't
know that everybody else was being taken
over by the Sinister Gene so to the
Lasser to the best of her knowledge
sinisters in the pit that's where he's
supposed to be she doesn't know that he
was released by The X-Men and so
literally she's like okay uh why is he
here right he's supposed to be in the
pit not only that when he does reappear
what he shows is that he's been
tampering with the genes of Nightcrawler
and turned him into this kind of
grotesque beast and so he's like the
Nightcrawler that's been with you is the
one that I created so I could tamper
with the real night crawler up his jeans
and you would never know the difference
so you got an option either you can deal
with this puppet that I have installed
and you can just kind of go from there
you can join our cause or we can take
you out and so what ends up happening is
that with storm and one of the reasons
why she was able to avoid all this is
incredibly simple so what Sinister had
been doing when it came to him taking
over and everybody being infiltrated
what Sinister had done is he had
modified the resurrection machine and
what would happen is that every time a
mutant was killed and resurrected they
would be secretly infected with the
Sinister Gene that's how he was able to
take everybody over storm was not
infected by that because if you guys
remember during Judgment Day storm got
rid of her of her backup in the
resurrection protocols so that if she
dies she stays dead there's no
conceivable way of bringing her back
Magneto also did the same thing and so
the result of this is that storm is not
infected because she hasn't been
resurrected since the tampering was done
by Mr Sinister and so in response to
that because they can't simply just kill
her because ultimately if the quiet
Council killed storm it would ultimately
result in a civil war because she's so
respected by mutants on both sides
especially the ones that haven't been
taken over yet and so what ends up
happening is that Professor Xavier and
Emma Frost used their telepathy to try
to control the mind of storm and so what
we end up doing is transitioning back or
kind of jumping back to a bit of a
flashback when storm is meeting with
laktuka I think is how you pronounce
their name but latuka is basically a
member of the great Ring of Oracle right
the governing body of Mars basically and
everybody on the governing body of Mars
is an Omega Level mutant which of course
means that there are some of the most
powerful mutants in existence with
lactica or laktuka however you pronounce
it that basically they have the ability
to know everything that's going on right
just Universal maybe even multiversal
awareness but more so than that they
house like an infinite number of minds
and the result of this is that when they
basically back up the mind of of storm
what it means is that when Xavier and
Emma Frost launched their telepathic
attack it's not just trying to take over
the mind of storm is trying to take over
an infinite number of Minds at the same
time which of course they can't do it's
one person standing on a beach trying to
hold back a tidal wave that's 300 feet
tall and 500 feet wide right it's not
gonna happen you know what I mean you're
just going to be engulfed by that thing
and that's going to be the end of you
and so this basically allows storm to go
without being infected by Xavier and
Emma Frost she cast down this amazing
lightning bolt and she's just like
Abominations right imposters and then
takes off right literally just leaves
and so that's when she comes to the
realization This Is War right that's
basically what this is this is now a
civil war among the mutants those who
are infected and those who were not now
the cool thing about this is that as
storm makes like if she literally make
readies her forces she's met by the
arrival of Destiny and Mystique remember
Destiny can see the future she's a
precog it's not all in stone so if
Destiny comes to you and says this is
going to happen in five minutes it's the
absolute truth if she comes to you and
says this is going to happen in five
years it may or may not happen because a
lot of things can take place between now
and five years so again it's not an
absolute prediction but she is the most
trusted precog that's out there but she
tells storm if you go and attack the
X-Men now you are guaranteed to lose we
have to abide our time we have to wait
and so the result of this is that we
transition to essentially Sebastian Shaw
of the hellfire club now Sebastian Shaw
has been kind of a background character
for quite some time but he becomes an
emissary to the Realms of hell right to
the Realms of limbo but what this does
is it allows the X-Men to conquer all
the different hell Realms right the
Realms of Mephisto and all those
different guys beyond that you have
magic who actually or at least Ileana
Rasputin who ends up making a deal on
behalf of the X-Men with Serta from
muspelheim because what had happened is
that when the Avengers became more and
more extreme leading up to them
attacking the U.S government Thor
ultimately vacated he abandoned The
Avengers heartbroken and ended up just
residing in uh in Asgard and staying
there seemingly permanently but with
magic making a deal with cerder in order
to destroy Asgard she gets the Twilight
sword which is literally the sword of
Ragnarok right like that's the source a
sword sort of would use to wipe out
everything in Asgard she shows up here
using her magical abilities and destroys
Asgard and the asgardians are cast out
into the abyss never to be seen or heard
from again on top of that Sinister and
the X-Men they wipe out Juan to maximoff
right they destroy the Scarlet Witch
because remember during the events of
House of M leading up to House of M she
had the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale she could set everything
back and so what ends up happening
during this time is that Sinister right
it's like you know continuing to skip
forward through time Sinister ends up
using the Westchester Institute the
Xavier school for gifted youngsters as a
gigantic lab and he literally starts
splicing together the genes of different
mutants into like a singular body so you
might have like the genes of Colossus
that are merged with the genes of
nightcrawlers so you have like night
Colossus which is kind of an awesome
name if I'm being honest with you guys
right okay so here's what here's what I
want you guys to do here's what I want
you guys to do leave a comment down
below with like spliced names right so
like if you were gonna merge like
Wolverine and cyclops or like if you
were gonna if you're gonna name the
merger of like Nightcrawler and Colossus
give me those names man because I really
want to see them right I think it would
be awesome but using these splice jeans
what it does is it allows the X-Men to
become more powerful than they ever were
before because now they possess multiple
Powers so an army composed of 100 X-Men
suddenly becomes what is in effect 200
X-Men because each one of those X-Men
now has two Powers 100 times 2 is 200 so
literally that's one of the crazy things
because when that happens an attack is
lost by Sinister the X-Men and all those
guys against the forces of storm right
all those guys out there and so what we
end up doing is jumping forward 10 years
and what we end up finding out here is
that the human population is by and
large aware of what's going on but they
don't care right they realize like they
want to be a part of this greater thing
that Sinister has kind of created the
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants but he's done it in a nefarious
way he's done it through mind control
right he's done it through conquering
and all that kind of stuff it's kind of
nuts and so what we end up doing is
basically picking up during this 10-year
time Jump when Sinister is meeting with
the Quiet Council and the quiet Council
actually reveals that what they've been
doing is modifying the programming of
the Sinister Gene in each one of
themselves so they don't operate as a
slave of Mr Sinister instead they
operate as their own individual person
doing their own individual thing they
still operate under the guise or at
least still operate with the idea of the
X-Men conquering everything but they're
not like dogs on a leash for sinister
you know what I mean but in effect this
leads Sinister to realize he's lost
control of the people that he's supposed
to be in controlling he's lost control
of the Kawaii Council they have too much
free will and so what his intention is
is to basically go back and wipe the
entire project right literally wipe them
all out and that'll basically be it and
then effectively start over the issue is
that once he gets back there he realizes
the entirety of his lab is gone his
ability to rework this whole process
doesn't exist anymore someone's stolen
his lap and so in effect he's now
trapped down here there's no conceivable
means for him to escape so he literally
loses control of his own project he
always ends up losing here and that's
where it sends a Sinister Leaf let me
know okay okay do we need to cover the
rest of this because it's not completely
done yet right like it's still coming
out on a monthly basis so I don't know
exactly how long it'll take to finish
but like do we need to cover this man
because honestly this story is dope it's
one of the most interesting stories I've
seen with the X-Men in so long
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with sins of sinister and I
love this story oh my God now one of the
things to remember right these three
number ones that we've done so far storm
in the Brotherhood nightcrawlers which
is coming out later this week and then
this one immoral X-Men this all takes
place in the first 10 years the number
twos that are going to be coming out
take place during 100 years and then the
final three issues take place at 1 000
years so again 10 years 100 years
thousand years so during this 10-year
window which is really when the X-Men
first start taking over everything and
conquering the world that we basically
have an attempt by really Nick Fury and
I love that I'd call them his Howling
Commandos but basically what's left of
Shield launching a strike force against
Westchester in order to take down the
ability for the X-Men to effectively
control everybody right the cerebro
satellite in the sky that kind of
monitors everything that everybody has
going on all the time now one of the
crazy things about this is that it's
Nick Fury in them begin to launch their
mesh and they jump out of this window
their brains shut down and they smash
into the ground and die only for us to
find out Xavier had basically screwed
with their heads this is nuts man it's
one hell of a way to open a comic book
to be honest with you guys I love it
like I absolutely love the way this was
done now the funny thing about this is
that this is literally just Xavier
saying another cell's gone and that's
what's cool about this because what it
shows us is that when it comes to these
different Rogue factions that are trying
to work against the X-Men in order to
stop them from Conquering the world that
some of them have the ability to dodge
the influence of Professor Xavier in
other telepaths now that's not unheard
of anybody who's been reading X-Men for
any real measure of time knows and
honestly I would say using Tech to
overcome the power of telepaths that
didn't really become a big thing until
the 90s you saw people doing it during
the Run of Chris Claremont back here in
the 70s and the 80s but in truth the 90s
is when like everything in Marvel was
like super high octane fast paced and
like all kinds of high-tech stuff and so
during this time it was not uncommon to
see people overcome the power of
telepaths using technology Cy scans is
what they were at least a size Shields
is what they would call them but the
cool thing about this is that Xavier
having done this he actually kind of
starts to cry because even even though
what they're doing is quote unquote in
the eyes of the X-Men bringing about a
kind of peace to the world that
otherwise wouldn't exist it still brings
them a lot of Anguish to know that
there's somebody just wiping people out
and his stance is really more like why
can't they just succumb to our Dream now
it's kind of a funny thing because
depending on where you stand morally you
can kind of take one side of the other
right like Xavier tried to do the dance
he tried to do the whole thing where
it's like let's work together guys and
Humanity didn't want to do it so the
response of Xavier is well if you don't
want to do it willingly then we will
make you right we will make you accept
our existence now the undercurrent here
and it's one of the things to keep in
mind Sinister isn't really controlling
all of them but they are operating more
based on what Sinister would do as
opposed to anything else we'll talk a
little bit more about that is because
that'll be a main focal point as we get
through this but unlike Xavier who still
maintains his Humanity Emma Frost
doesn't care and that's one of the
things Emma Frost has always been
cold-blooded and this this comic is
actually just gonna lay him a frost bear
not literally but you are going to see
like Emma Frost for who she is and
really just how cunning and dark she can
be and so it's really kind of a funny
thing because what ends up happening
here is you have a quiet counselor or at
least the quiet counsel that's brought
together by Emma Frost and one of the
things they initially do is they kind of
ask the question of Hope Summers why do
you have a cybernetic arm now the reason
why Hope Summers does this is because
it's paying tribute to Cable remember
cable's not dead but he defected from
the X-Men and he joined Storm's
Brotherhood and is kind of doing his
thing at this point in time working
against the attempt of sinister to
conquer everything now the reason why
this matters and we covered it but truth
to tell we might go back and rework all
that mid-2000s X-Men stuff after
decimation but one of the things that
happened here is that after decimation
when all the mutants lost their early
like 98 of the mutant population lost
their powers due to the action of
Scarlet Witch Hope Summers was the first
mutant born after that happened now it
did turn into a kind of cat and mouse
game where the mutant Bishop was trying
to kill hope cable was trying to keep
her safe so literally cable was just
taking hope through time they were
jumping around the time stream and
Bishop was chasing after them but the
important thing is that hope is viewed
as the Messiah but the fact that she was
raised by Cable in a lot of ways she
sees cable as her father this is even
doubly important because of the fact
that her parents were killed when she
was a baby so she never actually knew
her parents Cable's the only Father
Figure she's ever known so that's why
you have such a strong father-daughter
bond between the two of them but the
thing about this and what's really kind
of interesting here is you switch over
to Sinister now Sinister again with his
diamond with a diamond on his head
remember he's one of four sinisters that
exist out there and none of them seem to
be aware of the others but what is
important here and what we really what
we saw at the end of the sins of
sinister one shot is that what he was
doing was clonimore mchaggard so he
could basically kill her if he needed to
reset the time stream because that's her
power and then he would basically remind
himself of everything that was going on
and then restart this attempt to conquer
the world in case something went awry
the problem with this and as we know now
from the storm and the Brotherhood comic
storm under forces stole the cloning lot
they stole the secret lab of sinister
and so what he's really trying to do
here is figure out what comes next
because without the ability to kill a
mctaggard and reset the time
stream he's stuck in this timeline until
whatever degree it plays out now one of
the other other things that's kind of
funny here is that when he teleports
back to just one of his safe havens he's
got those all over the world but when he
teleports back to one of them he's
basically got a clone of himself he's
not overly intelligent it's really just
a way for sinister to just bounce ideas
off of himself but one of the things he
makes a comment on is that he might go
meet with dark Beast now here's the
thing I didn't even know dark Beast
existed anymore maybe I'm missing
something but as far as I'm aware dark
beasts has been out of Marvel Comics for
ages if he is here that's kind of a cool
thing for those of you guys who don't
know the significance of that back in
the 1990s Marvel had a comic called The
Age of Apocalypse which was a really
really fun and amazing comic book story
if you were a fan of the villain
apocalypse and even like everybody else
in Marvel it was just really cool the
way it was handled the important thing
here is that in that reality instead of
Beast being the more jovial member of
the X-Men who was like the Science Guy
slash cheerleader so on and so forth in
the Age of Apocalypse he was twisted
like he was really really twisted and he
would perform like gruesome experiments
on people that's how he earned the name
dark beast but when the Age of
Apocalypse timeline was ended when that
timeline was destroyed dark Beast was
one of a precious few number of
characters which included oh my God
Holocaust he made it out God I am God I
loved his character oh my God he was
amazing one of the one of the best
characters from the 90s that you've
never heard of if you never grew up
reading Marvel Comics of the 1990s he
was cool he was a really really cool
concept of course X-Man Nate gray also
escaped the timeline I think sugar man
did as well I don't know of anybody else
that made it out but the important thing
here is that dark beasts made it out of
the timeline and just kind of existed in
Marvel for a little while so again I'm
not 100 sure of dark Beast is here maybe
he is but regardless it is a cool little
reference right to the potential fact
that he is here but at the end of the
day Sinister comes to the realization
that only he can really trust himself to
get out of that because what he's done
is he's created a kind of backup plan
this idea at least under normal
circumstances is that he had what was
called The Inferno protocol which was
literally a doomsday button he would
just smash this button and it would kill
everybody under his control and then in
turn he could just go and reactivate the
timeline if he needed to but the reality
here is that doomsday button is in a
secret lab so literally any option he
has to destroy these guys and one Fell
Swoop is all basically gone so he's got
to do it piece by piece and so he ends
up showing up in the room of Emma Frost
while she's sleeping with what's
basically a lethal injection goes to
take her out only for the needle to
break and that's what we end up finding
out it's Emma Frost's inner Diamond form
more so than that the reason why the the
needle broke on her skin is because she
looked like she was in her normal form
but she wasn't and what's actually been
happening here is she's been holding
Jason Wingard prisoner in her own room
in order to basically trick anybody who
comes in there into believing that she's
just in her normal form she literally
keeps them hopped up on amphetamines all
the time the guy stays awake all the
time or really just kind of sleeps
during the day but like stays up all
night long in order to ensure that she's
protected lest he fails to do his job
and then pays the price which would
likely be psychic torture and then
probably not being able to spend the
night with him a frost anymore so the
thing about this in and what's really
crazy here
is that Emma Frost realizing what's
going on ultimately ends up attacking
Sinister or at least traveling back to
capture Sinister once Sinister teleports
away now what's funny about this is that
in response not only has Sinister been
combining the powers of different
mutants in the Chimera he's also been
combining them into weapons so he
literally has this gun that he uses that
basically combines the power of Banshee
and Cipher in the sense that because
Cipher can speak any language he
basically uses the gun to blast Emma
Frost with a Sonic Blast but the power
of Cipher allows the gun to decipher
exactly what frequency Emma Frost
Diamond form is at so that it can be
broken and that's kind of the crazy
thing is because he literally shatters
her arm and there's kind of a brief
reprieve here because one of the things
that had gone on here is Sinister would
come to the realization that if he
really is going to try to take over the
world and he's going to use the X-Men to
do it and intended to keep them under
his control it was only a matter of time
before somebody was able to kill them
off and so what he did or at least what
the X-Men seemed to do was develop the
Logan patch much like a nicotine patch
where the Logan patch does is it
literally just kind of keeps your blood
filled with Logan's healing factor and
so when Emma Frost reverts back to her
human form her arm regrows so again it's
cool I love that like Marvel is kind of
taking all these little tidbits from all
these characters and just combine them
into just this incredibly amazing story
and so literally when when Emma Frost
heals herself it's only a matter of time
before she destroys Sinister so Sinister
pulls out yet another Ace on the hole
and unleashes the Cyclops Chimera
basically these different people out
here who are are effectively sinisters
rebranded version of the nasty boys they
were a team as Sinister had back in the
day they really gained their prominence
through an X-Men the Animated Series is
when like they became the most popular
but they were kind of like a sinister's
second version of the Marauders more or
less but the nasty boys were kind of
like his own henchmen but what he's done
here is he's taken the optic blast of
Cyclops and combined them into other
people for example Groot seemingly has
the ability to shoot opted glass out of
his eyes and other parts of his body
which I'm not gonna lie is kinda dope
like to be honest with you guys like
that's pretty awesome but literally it's
it's nuts because somebody like Ruckus
for example his eyes have been turned
into an optic Blaster the ability to
shoot object blast but because the power
of ruckus was to emit a concussive
scream from his mouth that what would
happen is an optic blast was attached to
his mouth which seemingly amplify and
amplifies the power of the optiblast so
again it's cool the way this was done
and it's really like Emma Frost as she
starts to manipulate these guys issues
like I know Cyclops inside and out and
in fact I was in love with Cyclops for
the longest time and what she says is
like there's no version of Cyclops that
exists out there that I cannot
manipulate that I cannot somehow trick
into fighting himself in some capacity
so literally using her telepathy she
gets into the mind of the nasty boys and
they all start attacking each other and
then she has like this amazing speech
right she says power is not what you are
power is what you do true Queens are
self-made not appointed and whether
those who bestow the titles are Gods
scientists or monarchs Emma Frost kneels
to no one and everyone kneels to me I am
the Divine Emma Frost and you've never
been higher than dying red-faced before
me it's pretty awesome because here's
the thing Emma Frost is one of these
characters where like she exists in
Marvel and she does some stuff sometimes
but she's never quite gotten her do the
way that she deserves and I'm still
waiting for a story that Marvel does
where Emma Frost is elevated to this
massive prominence because let's be
honest with ourselves during Civil War
they established that Emma Frost is more
powerful than Professor Xavier so it's
only a matter of time before Marvel
could write a story and it would
legitimately be believable where Emma
Frost either conquers the world or Kills
the Marvel universe or something like
that because she's an Omega Level
telepath what would be Thai the poor
soul that crosses Emma Frost with
nefarious intent right it's just it's
amazing like the way the way her
character functions but she ultimately
overpowers uh Nathaniel Essex and then
what he does is he reveals to her that
with these Chimera that he's created
where he can combine two powers that
given his research he's developed the
ability to put five powers in one
individual person now imagine that for a
second because when you look at
characters like Hope Summers who's an
Omega Level mutant and has the ability
to duplicate the powers of anybody she
meets and then presumably hold on to
those Powers forever or somebody like
Rogue who can touch a person and then
absorb their Consciousness or at least
in the Years leading up to the heckatome
storyline where she could actually
absorb multiple Powers into her own body
right like that that makes them a force
to be reckoned with and that's what
sinister's talking about creating here
the most powerful mutants to ever exist
in the history of the Marvel Universe
it's an astronomical situation right and
so Emma Frost realizing not only that
this could be done but she could
actually have it done to herself she
comes to this realization and even when
Sinister says you're all going to end up
Waging War against each other right like
absolute power corrupts absolutely
you're all working together now but it's
only a matter of time before those eyes
have compromised turn into eyes of envy
and you all start looking at each other
like well when are they going to make a
move against me and paranoia sets in and
you destroy yourselves but Emma Frost
looking at this comes to the realization
that if she's able to attain the right
combination possibly before anybody else
does she can take over the world she
could kill everybody and she could
literally conquer the world on her own
and there'd be no one to stand in her
way and so what she does is she convenes
a meeting of the quiet Council and then
gives them a kind of telepathic brief on
everything that's transpired of course
probably leaving out a few details
involving her own machinations and then
ask the question do we allow Nathaniel
Essex to continue with his experiments
or do we kill him or possibly even
submit him down to the to the great
chasm right to the abyss and the result
of the quiet Castle the verdict is we
let him continue so they welcome him
back into their ranks but sinister's on
a short leash and while Emma Frost
doesn't say it in so many words the
reality is that Nathaniel Essex days are
numbered right like once he finishes
this unless he's able to present an even
better scenario unless he's able to
basically provide himself or prove
himself as a person that has any kind of
contribution That Matters To The Quiet
counsel if he can't do that they're
going to take him out right and as we
know from sins of sinister the one shot
they ultimately do so it's a really
really cool situation
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the first part of sins of
sinister and this story is amazing okay
so check this out so one of the things
to remember with sins of sinister is
that what Mr Sinister had been doing is
that one there's four of them not just
one and each one believes that they are
like the main Sinister but the Sinister
that we know with the diamond on his
head that he had basically been duping
the X-Men that every time an X-Men was
killed and then brought back to life or
really any Mutant was killed and brought
back to life that they had a gene
planted inside of them that would allow
Sinister to take control of them right
to literally control their mind and so
what we saw in the original one shot
that said all this in motion is that
over the years in Marvel Comics going
into the future that Sinister had used
this to basically conquer the world and
then ultimately his Creations
essentially turned against him so what
this does is this basically picks up in
the time when the X-Men are conquering
everything it is really like a Civil War
in a lot of ways and the reason why is
because this one focuses on storm so
what we know about storm for the most
part is that she resides on Mars she's
like the queen of the Iraqi people the
other half of the mutant population that
we simply didn't know existed but in the
early days of sinister's forces taking
over the world that as they were going
through and attacking different groups
though one of the first groups they
attacked with a group of the Iraqi on
Mars because they're some of the most
powerful mutants in existence so getting
rid of them as fast as possible is the
best way to kind of clear the landscape
and make Conquest easier for sinister
and all of his forces and so what storm
talks about here is that she recalls
back to when the quiet Council seem to
be getting more and more extreme she
didn't actually know that Sinister had
been controlling them she just felt like
the quiet Council had moved away from
trying to turn uh krakowa into a place
where mutants could reside in safety
from the mutant population and it
started going on a mission of conquest
and so one storm had realized that
Sinister was controlling the quiet
Council she had made retreated when she
realized there was no way to destroy
them but when Destiny the precognitive
showed up and told her now is not the
time to attack that storm started
marshaling her forces and initially they
were just gonna wait right they were
gonna take Destiny's advice and just
wait for the best time to attack but of
course Sinister attacked them using
Chimera now Chimera are basically the
examples of where Sinister is taking
different mutants and merging them
together we'll learn more about that in
the nightcrawlers comic which is amazing
like it looks like it's going to be so
cool I'm so excited to read it but of
course as you would expect by having a
chimera of mutants the forces of storm
are almost completely and totally
obliterated and they have a whole host
of people at their disposal it includes
Richard Ryder Nova people like that but
because blending Omega Level mutants
together and in effect they are greater
than the sum of their parts means the
forces of storm never really even had a
chance they never quite had a chance to
even overcome these guys and so all this
left here is death and destruction the
only thing that storm and her forces
what's left of them could possibly do
was just Flee for their lives but with
them just kind of out there and
basically remaining hidden the way this
works is by way of whiz kid now whiz kid
we've talked about before but it's kind
of a refresher here this was a kid that
has the ability to create and control
any kind of Machinery he can possibly
imagine there's no limit there so you
could even argue he's Way Beyond Tony
Stark or Reed Richards or any of those
guys but the long and short of this is
that he was able to develop a cloaking
device that would in effect hide the
storm and her Brotherhood from the
forces of sinister they'd never be able
to locate them and so what we end up
finding out here is that Destiny has
approached storm yet again but this time
storm is a little more apprehensive
because the last time she took took
Destiny's advice they were ambushed and
almost the entirety of her and her
forces were eradicated and so what's so
crazy about this is that while this
meeting is taking place between storm
and Destiny that storm asked this guy
named John if it really is Destiny
herself and John's response is it's not
now we don't really know anything about
this guy we'll talk about him here in a
second but he immediately attacks
Destiny because he senses a few things
one her uh her energy signature is not
the same her mannerisms are different
right there are things about her her
body language and so on and so forth
none of it looks like Destiny or even
sounds like Destiny if you're paying
close enough attention now when this guy
makes his move we end up finding out
that it's not Destiny it's actually a
Mystique and this particular guy isn't
his named John iron fire now again we
don't really know anything about him
he's just one of these mutants is
seemingly existed out there on kakawa
but Marvel heavily heavily implies the
idea that this guy is Omega Level in
fact Mystique literally asks though I
thought only omegas could serve on the
great Ring is this a rule that died with
your planet or are you the Omega of
molten metal blood now there's different
ways to interpret this one is of course
the rule that only Omega Level mutants
can serve on the great Ring of oracco is
no longer intact it's literally storm
just marshalling whoever she can and
forming the council out of whoever's
left so being able to pick and choose
about what person you have just isn't
quite there it could also be this guy
quite literally is an Omega Level Newton
and I would argue that is the latter and
the reason why is because John has the
ability to create any metal in existence
using his own blood now there's nothing
to directly indicate that he can or
cannot create adamantium but it's
possible he could actually blend
adamantium with other metals mysterium
or vibranium or something like that and
actually create a whole new form of
metal that's never been seen before
that's more durable than adamantium or
any of those but the long and shorter
that's the reason why this is so cool is
because what we end up getting is
Mystique who's here with a mission for
storm now one of the things to know is
that storm under any normal circumstance
would never jeopardize her forces she
would never jeopardize any of her guys
what's left of her forces she would
never send them on some kind of random
errant but what Mystique reveals here is
the true power of sinister that with
Sinister it's not simply just taking
everybody under mind control and then
trying to conquer the world the reality
here is he could fail multiple times for
any number of reasons and in light of
the fact that he could fail he has a
kind of reset that he developed remember
one of the things that Jonathan Hickman
established in his run on the X-Men
which we turned into a full story is
like 13 hours if you haven't seen it
already there's a link to it down in the
description it covers the entirety of
Jonathan Hickman's run of the X-Men but
one of the things he established is that
Maura McTaggart who in years past was
just a mutant geneticist and a really
good friend of Professor X the leader of
the X-Men that she was actually a mutant
and her power is that every time she
died the timeline reset and she would
basically come back as her but
remembering everything that had happened
before this is sinister's McGuffin right
it says Ace in the Hole if for whatever
reason he were to fail he can basically
just activate one of the Clones of
Mormon Tigard and then kill her and
that'll reset everything but Sinister
will remember it all he'll remember
everything that that clone of more
McTaggart remembers basically everything
that's happened so it gives him the
ability to kind of reset everything to
zero but correct the mistakes that he
made and so knowing this that seemingly
storm comes to the realization of what
Mystique is saying that so long as the
Clones of sinister are in his possession
there's no conceivable way they could
win there's no possible way they could
come out on top every time they defeat
Sinister if he somehow manages to escape
one of the Clones will die everything
will get reset and they'll ultimately
end up taking or he'll ultimately end up
launching his campaign all over again
and so with the face of that knowledge
there's only one thing storm can do
which is launch an attack now this is
when we get into the Brotherhood
themselves and in truth it's composed of
some pretty Heavy Hitters right so right
off the bat you've got storm who is of
course an Omega Level mutant that can
control the weather on any world that
she's on and even manipulate whether
that happens in space right storms and
different things like that you've got
cable who speaks for himself right for
those of you guys who don't know who
know who cable is he's one of the most
powerful telepaths and telekinetics in
the history of Marvel Comics Cora of
course is not Cora from The Legend of
Korra she's not a bender uh or an avatar
even though she was nowhere near as
interesting as king uh not not Kang
there we go
King the Conqueror The Last Airbender
which is a story I would absolutely read
uh the core has the ability to boost the
power of anybody in her vicinity and
move it to a higher level of course with
kid we've already talked about iron fire
we've already talked about quick
basically uh lulo Marshall she's
basically the fastest being that's still
living right so seemingly Quicksilver is
no longer alive here and then of course
you've got Mystique who's not really
officially part of the Brotherhood but
it's just kind of there along for the
rod but the thing about this is that as
everybody shows up here right once they
arrive to where uh sinister's base is
which is actually a more metagger's
former base of operations as soon as
they show up there we end up finding
that Chimera are guarding the place
specifically it's maggot and Marrow who
have been merged into one now this is
crazy because one of the things Miro was
able to do in Marvel Comics and she's
basically old school
um she could kind of grow bones out of
her body that she could like throw at
you but maggot had the ability ability
and really it was only only came in the
form of two but he had these kind of
maggots that would basically consume
energy form but they could consume
anything in existence it didn't matter
what it was and that energy once they
consumed it would be fed back into uh
into maggot himself which would
basically either sustain him or even
bolster his own abilities but the thing
about this is that by combining the two
it's quite literally having maggot bones
thrown at you these bones will be thrown
at you and they will consume you it's a
pretty dangerous thing right imagine
somebody just throwing piranha that
could eat anything in the world or
anything in existence imagine them
throwing uh throwing those at you and
that's what you're facing off against
right now it's a pretty wicked
combination and I love the idea right I
honestly kind of hope this is going to
be one of those Age of Apocalypse types
things where like some of these folks
survive into the main timeline when this
kind of future ends or is somehow
averted or whatever the case happens to
be and we get them going forward into
the future of Marvel Comics because it'd
be amazing using
honestly I can't really even remember
the last time that I talked about like
maggot mirror or any of those guys but
again once Storm's forces overcome them
overcome those Chimera they get into the
base of operations they meet even more
but the bigger issue here is that with
the cloning system of sinister it's
basically met with an impenetrable force
field and so the cool thing about this
is that as this discussion Goes Down And
as we're trying to figure out what to do
here what Wizkid does is he comes up
with this idea of instead of trying to
like take down the force field which
they just don't have time to do to sit
there and run like a whole bunch of
algorithms and try to figure out the
best and most effective way to do it
because the forces are closing in they
can only hold them off for so long that
what ends up happening is that instead
the Brotherhood basically teleports the
whole system away right they teleport
the entire uh cloning facility away so
during the sins of sinister one shot
when Sinister came back to his base of
operations and the entire cloning
facility was gone on and then he was now
stuck in this timeline this is how it
happened right it had seemingly happened
quite some time before Sinister himself
realized what was going on right because
by the time he realized that his cloning
facility had gone something like 50
years or so had passed or 10 years or
something to that effect so it's been
gone for quite a while but the other
part of this is that as storm and whiz
kid are watching the system teleport and
then preparing to make their leave we
end up finding out Wizkid is not
actually whiz kid that with a whiz kid
is a Mystique impersonating Wizkid not
only that here's the cool thing about
this right she literally kind of taunts
John by asking were you able to figure
out that it was me this time and the
reason for the reason for why John was
able to deduce that it was not Destiny
and actually Mystique was because
Mystique allowed him to and I imagine
those are the guys who are probably
watching this or listening to this or
even read the comic when it first came
out you were kind of like no way some
random mutant is going to be able to
figure out that like it's not Destiny
and that is actually a Mystique unless
there were some kind of telepath because
Mystique is far too Adept at her powers
to simply just figure out that it's
someone else somebody like Wolverine
could do it just by picking up sense but
then again over the years in Marvel
Comics we've seen mystique's abilities
move to a place where she can even trick
Wolverine now the only real person out
there who's a shape-shifter who's so
capable that no one can really figure
out who they are outside of some high
level telepath would be like Vanessa
Carlisle right like copycat the
girlfriend of Deadpool in the the fox
Deadpool films that's the only one who
can really do it because copycat cannot
just copy the physical form of a mutant
she can also copy their powers right so
she can literally block her existence or
anybody that she's uh that she's copying
from like any telepath if she's
duplicating a telepath right so it's
cool right she can like copy the powers
of Charles Xavier and have some measure
of telepathy but after basically
stabbing storm and seemingly killing her
this basically leads to uh Mystique Body
sliding by one out of that location I.E
teleporting away and then of course John
Ironside runs to the side of storm and
while she's not dead of course the goal
is to get a medical Evac in there so
they can get her out of there get her
treatment and get her healed again and
so at that point we jump to Destiny and
we have Destiny basically here at the
world Farm now remember the world Farm
is a place out there on the far reaches
of the universe right at the very edge
of the universe and what we end up
finding out is that Destiny Ever the
pre-cock and ever aware of what's going
on around her and always looking to the
Horizon right that's one of the things
about Destiny while everybody's running
around and focusing on the here and now
she's 10 steps ahead almost every single
time that's her gift and her role of
being able to see and understand the
future as always and one of the things I
want to mention here if Destiny tells
you something's gonna happen in five
minutes take it as an absolute truth if
she tells you something's gonna happen
in five years keep it in the back of
your head because it may not come to
fruition but Destiny is always on the
move and she's always being Guided by
her Visions it's why the old Destiny
diary story in the X-Men Comics were so
important those of you guys who remember
the destiny diary stories those were
great back in the day it was really cool
one of the last great X-Men stories
before the huge reboot with House of M
but the thing about this is that of
course Destiny being here at the world
Farm we end up finding out that she's
talking to one of the other sinisters
specifically the one with the Spade on
his head and so it's kind of crazy here
because this is basically one of the
sinisters seemingly aware of what the
other Sinister is doing but trying to
find a way to bring his campaign to an
end we don't know fully what role he's
going to play or how far reaching his
actions are or if he's just hiding the
fact that he wants to do exactly what
Sinister did but wants to see the
diamond Sinister taken out but whatever
the case is I'm sure we'll find out by
the end of this story
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with sins of sinister and in
this one we're covering nightcrawlers
which is amazing because the ending of
this is gonna be pretty nuts so here's
the way this works so as you guys know
with the Sims of sinister storyline that
Marvel is basically releasing three
different Comics essentially that show
us what's going on during this 10-year
time period going into the future when
Sinister basically conquers everything
and so what this does is this initially
picks up in the sanctum Saint torm right
of doctor strange and what we end up
having here is in effect Banshee now
this is a version of Banshee that we
haven't really talked about yet and in
fact it's a version of his character
that has been introduced relatively
recently in the Legion of X storyline in
the new era of Marvel Comics X-Men stuff
but the idea behind this is this guy
possesses What's called the spirit of
variance with Banshee and with a spirit
of variance there's not a whole lot that
we know here because of the fact that
the spirit of variance was introduced so
recently and then immediately thrown
into this this is going to be one of the
those instances where we see the
capabilities of what the spirit of
variance can do and that as time
progresses Marvel will likely build on
it but the spirit of variance was at one
point a spirit of Vengeance and this is
one of the big changes that Marvel's
making to the nature of Ghost Rider the
Ghost Rider Mythos itself that when it
comes to the spirits of Vengeance they
weren't really a collective of beings
that existed out there that instead the
spirit Avengers was more of a concept it
was the General name given to the dark
Persona of a Ghostwriter but the reality
here is that how that Ghost Rider gained
their powers changed from one Ghost
Rider to the next and so what Marvel's
doing here is they're introducing this
idea that the spirits of Vengeance are
more like a spiritual Collective that
exists out there not that dissimilar
from like Cosmic entities but
drastically less powerful seemingly and
that the spirit of variance was at one
point a spirit of Vengeance but unlike
the other spirits of Vengeance it
effectively kind of changed its ways
decided to go a different route and was
more peaceful in nature as opposed to
destructive and this led to the spirits
of Vengeance effectively casting it out
so again this may be one of those things
where it may not necessarily stand the
test of time which is to say in like
five years somebody's gonna get rid of
it and you'll never see or hear from the
spirit of errands again and it'll kind
of go back to just being the traditional
spirit of Vengeance that exists out
there but again you know it's just a
it's a cool little change to see whether
or not it's six of the general audience
or whether or not Marvel keeps it but
that's why you see this different
variation of bands here this different
appearance of Banshee now the cool thing
about this is that in the middle of that
while he's here he's suddenly set upon
by What's called the Legion of the night
and this group is cool and it's one of
the coolest things that I've seen Marvel
do in recent years so one of the things
we had talked about in the sins of
sinister one shot which again you'll
find the playlist down in the
description if you want to get caught up
we're only two videos in so if there
really isn't a whole lot of catching up
to do there but one of the things that
we have found out is that during this
10-year time period dead Sinister was
creating what were basically Chimera a
sort of a merger of different mutants
and their powers that existed out there
but one of the things we learned beyond
that was finished they're sort of taking
over and possessing even non-mutant
beings that were out there Spider-Man is
an example of this and so what's in
effect happened here is that you have
toad you have saber tooth you have
Spider-Man you've got x-23 Laura Kinney
you have pyro you have people here right
looks like pixie I'm pretty sure but you
have people here who have basically been
merged with the powers of Nightcrawler
and what this does is it turns them into
sinister's most deadly assassins now I
wouldn't be surprised if Psy Superior
had taken like X-Men 2 remember like the
old Nightcrawler intro from the X-Men 2
film if that was his motivation for why
this was happening because that scene in
that movie made Nightcrawler cooler that
I think he'd ever been in the history of
Marvel Comics it was dope to see
Nightcrawler as an assassin jumping
through the White House and going after
the president so I'm not surprised if
this was like a major influence for that
but having characters like x-23 and
Spider-Man who have been taken over by
the power of sinister and their powers
have been augmented to basically include
the abilities of Nightcrawler where they
can teleport around it's cool because
they're basically everywhere plus the
Legion of the night is just a dope name
let's just say it guys like it's just
ridiculously cool but one of the funny
things about this is that these guys
have been on the hunt for Banshee for
quite some time now this is when we get
this small kind of adjustment to the
capabilities of what Banshee can do that
one of the things that happens here is
that in this fight he used What's called
the scream of change and this is kind of
a differentiation between like the
spirit of variance and like the spirit
of Vengeance the spirit of Vengeance if
we want to go that route and actually
accept that as a thing that it provides
its user with something called the pen
and stair and that's well known in the
Marvel Community among Ghost Rider fans
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with the pen and stair what it does is
that when it's used on someone it forces
them to feel the pain of everyone
they've ever heard over the course of
their life all at one time but with a
scream of change one ends up happening
is that when it's used on x23 it
actually breaks the the hold that
Sinister has on x-23 and when that
happens it actually leads to Banshee not
just using it on x23 but using it on
everybody else and in in essence
liberates them from the control of
sinister now one of the things right off
the bat is that we're told this is not
some kind of MacGuffin it's not some
kind of thing where all Banshee has to
do is just get like a really really big
bull horn and just shout into the air
and whole cities will be liberated from
sinister's control one of the things
we're told here is that they've tried
this multiple times on different people
who have been taken over by Sinister and
it doesn't work so for whatever reason
it seemingly works here so it's really
just a way for Spurrier to give us this
explanation of how this team can kind of
come into existence but it's not going
to be this way across the board
unilaterally as far as everyone being
possessed by Sinister on Earth not only
that what ends up happening here is once
this is done Banshee actually teleports
and meets with Mother righteous now
again mother righteous was also
introduced in Legion of x one of the
reasons why we kind of skipped over the
first volume of legion of X is because
it's not very important it's really just
kind of establishing what goes on with
Legion himself you don't really see any
like grandiose displays of his power or
anything along those lines is really
just kind of like here's what Legion and
like some other characters are doing
like at this point in time it's a setup
story it's really all it is volume two
is where things get really really cool
but volume one is by no means essential
at least if you're already familiar with
the characters if you don't know
anything about Legion or any of those
characters sure I guess it's essential
to a degree but the thing about this is
that what we find out from mother
righteous is that she's actually meeting
with orbis Stellaris as well as Dr
stasis now these are characters that we
have talked about before we covered
orbit Stellaris and Dr stasis after we
did the sins of sinister one shot and
what we learned is that the Mr sensor
that we've seen all these years in
Marvel Comics is just one version of him
that he's more or less a clone of the
original Nathaniel Essex that Dr stasis
and orbis Stellaris are the other clones
of sinister right so there were like
three down and one to go we didn't know
who the fourth clone was but as this
conversation happens between them one of
the things we find out here is that the
diamond Sinister is kind of operating
Rogue the other sinisters aren't really
on board with what he's doing per se but
the reality is to step into The Fray and
to somehow become involved it basically
risks them becoming controlled by
Sinister and if that were to happen
there wouldn't really be anybody out
there to effectively stand in the way of
sinister but what mother righteous has
been doing has actually been working on
really manipulating magic and so on and
so forth and trying to find a way to
ultimately end these kind of chimera
experiments of sinister but also working
behind the scenes to find the main base
of operations for sinister where he
basically has the more McTaggart clones
now we talked about that in the last
video that we did where we talked about
how more mctaggart's power was that
every time she died the timeline was
reset and so Sinister himself is the
only one that has possession of the
cloning facility and he has all these
different versions of more mctagon so
that if for some reason his experiment
goes awry he can kill one of the moras
reset time but he'll remember everything
right he'll literally have a kind of
database backup that will show him
everything that's happened in his own
mind he won't recall everything but
having it all in a computer system can
just go back and watch it basically
fills in the gaps form so we can
continue his experiment from there
becoming aware of what it was that would
happen like quite literally Sinister
would go to his base of operations and
he would say okay here's why the whole
experiment failed so now I'm going to
kill one of the Maury mctaggart's
Sinister when you watch this you'll
understand everything that went wrong
and you'll know where to make our
Corrections and though he'll just keep
doing that and doing that and doing that
until he has this kind of perfect
timeline where he rules and controls all
so having like Dr stasis and having
orbis Stellaris despite the fact that
they are clones of the original Sinister
just like the Sinister with a diamond on
his head they're actively trying to work
against him while not being overly
obvious about the fact that they're
trying to work against him but the issue
of mother righteous kind of casting
aside some of these spells actually runs
in the way of what Dr stasis was doing
while he was working with orcas again
the organization that normally would
stand against mutant populations but at
this point is trying to find a way to
defeat Sinister and one of the things he
says here is that orcas commissioned
that hex and while it lasted Sinister
was unable to exploit some of the most
dangerous Bloodlines now he's using the
Nightcrawler strain to build his hit
squats so to a degree while orcas is not
mutant friendly and orcas is the
organization that exists out there right
now trying to bring down the mutant
population the truth about it is that
they're standing against Sinister and
before Mother righteous had gotten
involved and kind of destroyed the hex
that was used by orcas that protected
these different uh really more advanced
Bloodlines from sinister's control
people like Nightcrawler for example
that once he did that she more or less
screwed everything up but she more or
less kind of torpedoed what orcas was
doing and that's how we have the Legion
of the night in the first place and so
one of the things that this really
picked up on here by Dr stasis is that
like the accent of mother righteous
which judging by the way that is spelled
or at least pronunciation Beyond based
on the way they dispelled it sounds like
uh was it Cockney English but one of the
things that goes on is that she
basically reveals she's the fourth
Sinister now if I'm a betting man to be
honest with you guys I don't think this
was the intention of Marvel which is why
I'm not making a great big huge scene
out of it otherwise it would have been
like and then she takes off her mask and
it turns out she's a four Sinister
there's a reason why I'm not doing that
because I don't think that was actually
supposed to be the case I think this is
what Marvel's doing because of the sins
of sinister event but the reality here
is that mother righteous doesn't have
enough history or even enough
significance in Marvel Comics for it to
actually matter right it's one of those
things where it's kind of like I mean
it's cool I guess whatever but it feels
more shoehorned in right in order to
like bolster the popularity of a
character that's just not that popular
in Marvel it would have been cooler if
it had turned out that like apocalypse
return and he's like one of the
sinisters or something along those lines
right by whatever Manner and whatever
means they want to make that happen it
would have been cool if that was the
case right somebody with a long-standing
bit of history that under normal
circumstances you never would have
expected to be a bad guy but has been
manipulating things behind the scenes
the whole time kind of like a Marvel or
I'm sorry a mutant version of like
Captain America during secret secret
Empire right but once this move is made
and once these other sinisters realize
that mother righteous is basically
trying to take them out because she is
in effect a good guy she's trying to
eliminate all the different versions of
sinister and just sort of go from there
you end up having doctor stasis that
makes this move while orbis Stellaris
watches all of it unfold and where he
does recall or at least use some of his
own forces to try to take them out
that's when you end up having the Legion
of the night who are now liberated and
operating under mother righteous who
show up and immediately attack Dr stasis
and so this guy ultimately ends up just
going the way of the dodo right that's
quite literally it and it's done in one
of the coolest ways ever because x-23
with a Nightcrawler abilities she has a
claw that comes out of her tail and this
is one of those things I didn't know I
needed this until I saw it this is dope
and I'm really really hoping this
version of x23 somehow survives the
whole sins of sinister timeline and ends
up in the main Marvel Universe because I
gotta tell you guys man x23 Laura Kinney
with the powers of Nightcrawler and like
an adamantium claw in her tail that's
pretty badass and I'm really hoping that
this stays
I really really do and so following the
defeat of Dr stasis basically uh mother
righteous has this kind of conversation
with orbis Stellaris where he literally
reveals I'm the one who stole the
cloning facility of sinister and I have
it in the world form it's a nigh
impregnable place you can't suddenly
just go in there so if you kill me
you'll never be able to access the
cleaning facility of sinister it'll be
gone forever but it'll literally
disappear for all time and we'll be
stuck in this timeline so either you can
stay out of my way and I'll give you
safe passures through my realm if that's
what you need or you can try to attack
me possibly even kill me and then we're
trapped in this reality until whenever
this timeline comes to a conclusion and
so mother righteous ultimately lets him
go which is really the smartest move to
make more so than that what she also
intends to do is to bolster her forces
and so the intention of really just the
Legion of the night alongside Banshee
being there is one part to try to find a
way to bolster their forces by freeing
other individuals whether it's because
these this kind of freed Legion of the
night wakes other people up or because
it's the powers of the spirit of
variance waking other people up much
like he woke up the Legion of the night
ultimately it doesn't necessarily work
of course it is a bit of a heist to a
degree where they're looking to steal
you know particular things they do end
up stealing a magical book which is not
the dark hole per se but it is a book
that allows mother righteous to
manipulate uh spells to a degree but the
bigger part of this is they have to find
a way to see if they can get into the
get into the the world form and so using
a kind of magical enchantment along with
the Spider-Man Nightcrawler merger that
basically is willing to sacrifice his
life because of the fact that for some
reason it's not fully explained those
individuals who are not mutants but are
possessed by Sinister they can't stay
freed for too long that the powers of
Banshee only work for so long and then
they'll eventually wear off and
Spider-Man would ultimately fall back
under the control of sinister and in
fact he says as much right I can feel
those forces I can feel the voice of
sinister creeping back in again it's
only a matter of time before I succumb
to his control and then I ultimately try
to kill all of you guys which for the
most part Spider-Man were the powers of
Nightcrawler could he's the privilege
assassin but with Peter Parker sack
sacrificing his life and with the team
now consisting of people like Colossus
as well as looks like a younger pixie
maybe magic is kind of weird kind of
hard to tell but with the team's roster
being bolstered by like one or two
people that Peter's life is sacrificed
when he literally tries to teleport into
the world form and ultimately perishes
in the conflict right perishes during
that time because he can't necessarily
break through but what mother righteous
realizes is that the force field is not
impregnable that given the right level
of power it can be broken through and so
what she does is she sends the rest of
the team on what is in effect a kind of
scavenger hunt right to basically steal
various magical artifacts that exist out
there these magical artifacts consist of
things like the dark hold right it looks
that looks like the uh The Siege
perilous I'm not 100 sure if it is if I
remember correctly it is the hammer of
Thor the eye of agamoto of doctor
strange and for those who were
eagle-eyed enough one of the helmets of
the black priest from Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers run right the
ability to manipulate magical words it's
like the black priests were in insanely
powerful they were able to like wipe out
whole worlds and different things like
that and Destroy entire groups of
Avengers in one Fell Swoop it was nuts
but this is basically some of the most
powerful magical artifacts in existence
across all of Marvel Comics that are
being used and being brought together by
mother righteous for the purpose of
taking down the world Farm These are
powers that in some ways rival the
abilities of cosmic entities
so storm goes beyond omega level and
becomes one of the most powerful mutants
to ever exist in the history of Marvel
Comics and it's nuts check this out so
this takes place during sins of sinister
but unlike the other videos that we did
that took place 10 years after Sinister
had basically conquered the world took
over the mutant population took over the
Avengers The Whole Nine Yards this takes
place a hundred years later so things
have changed drastically since the last
videos that we covered and not in a very
good way so this initially picks up with
Marvel boy also known as Novar a little
bit of History here this version of
Marvel boy was introduced back in 2000
in his own solo series he's okay I mean
in my personal opinion I think it was
just a an attempt by Marvel Comics to
take a Cree Warrior from an alternate
reality give him like insect DNA and
kind of make him like a blend between
like the cree and Spider-Man it was cool
Marvel boy does not suck he's fun to
read but that's just kind of my
perception on the character the
important thing here is that he's much
much older there now as a lot of you
guys are probably wondering would this
being a hundred years in the future why
aren't these people as old or even dead
like they should be one of the things to
remember is that when it came to the
X-Men on krakowa they had a lot of
technologies that came from the island
that allowed them to basically violate
death either it was Resurrection pills
that prolonged their life so there's a
lot of under the current stuff that was
already established that's just kind of
being rolled over into this and not a
lot of explanation is being given which
I think is a bad thing because I think
there are people who are unfamiliar with
the X-Men that are jumping on to simsa
Sinister and because it's kind of an
isolated self-contained story it can
cause problems but what is going on is
of course once they get to the ship and
they basically not only give the access
code for this round but the one that
actually comes the following week that's
when it's revealed they're actually
meeting with Destiny or at least
Destiny's on the ship and she's being
brought to meet with storm now there's
history here and we'll go over that over
the course of this video we'll make it
all make sense but Destiny's showing up
here things have gotten Bleak for her
because one of the things to know is
that yes while Destiny is a precognitive
meaning she can see the future one of
the things we've always talked about is
that her ability to decipher what's
going to happen is relative to how far
in the future she's looking if she tells
you something's going to happen in a
hundred years take it with a grain of
salt because a lot can happen between
now and 100 years from now but if she
says something's going to happen in five
minutes take it as an absolute truth the
thing about this is that she oftentimes
uses her own abilities to see the future
to kind of work for herself right to
ensure her own schemes and motivations
are satisfied first then she worries
about everybody else second so she's
like the most American person ever so
the thing here is that once she arrives
a lot of people have aged up right for
example cable is older than he was
before and in fact even his technology
has changed now the reason why I say
that is that for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with cable we are not
going to go into the origin of his
character because I made a 35 minute
video on that and even then I was
cramming stuff in you'll find a link to
that video pinned as a comment if you're
interested but cable is one half human
and one half machine but the
techno-organic virus was always like
eating away at his body what's going on
here is that he's now merged with a kind
of organic technology so it's more of a
symbiosis as opposed to a parasitic
infection but for Destiny herself what
we end up finding out is that somewhere
along the line Mystique left her right
Mystique left to go pursue her own
destiny in the sense that she wanted to
help the rebel forces try to defeat uh
Sinister and his forces the X-Men The
Avengers the surviving superheroes
basically anybody who was under the
influence of sinister what's so cool
about this is that when she did it she
reunited Freedom Force and as soon as I
saw that I was like Freedom Force no way
she's literally like on your feet
Freedom Force for the rebellion and I
was like bro like Freedom Force hasn't
been a thing in Marvel Comics for
decades unless I'm missing something
Freedom Force hasn't been a thing for
years the the important thing here
Freedom Force was basically mystique's
Brotherhood of evil mutants reworked
into a superhero team and working for
the commission on superhuman activity
specifically Valerie Cooper that all
happened during Chris claremont's run
back in the 1980s in the X-Men but
Freedom Force was amazing back then I
loved them it was one of the coolest
ideas ever but basically mystique's
death right she ended up dying for the
cause and so once Destiny finally gets
before storm storms a lot older than she
used to be but do not let her fool you
man she is every bit as powerful as she
used to be and actually more so like
it's nuts how capable she is but one of
the things Destiny says is that with the
death of Mystique it's now changed the
landscape because where a lot of her
mechanations and seeing the future and
kind of manipulating pieces and so on
were to ensure the survival of herself
and Mystique that they could have some
measure of a happy life together the
reality is that now things are different
right with Mystique being gone and out
of the picture now Destiny's focusing on
the bigger picture itself how do we find
a way to end the rule of sinister now
one of the things to remember here is
that there are a handful of sinisters
running around right now back in the day
in Marvel there was only one but what
we've learned is there's actually four
you have mother righteous you have orbis
Stellaris you've got the main Sinister
with the diamond on his head and then
you've got Dr stasis right so one of the
things to understand is that with sins
of sinister this story focuses on the
influence and the control of the
diamond-headed Sinister right the
original Sinister quote unquote if you
want to call them that but again what
goes on here is that a coming together
of storms forces alongside Destiny
launch an attack against orbis Stellaris
just one of the sinisters that are out
there it makes the most logical sense
because the stories of storm focus more
on space than anything else but taking
out each one of the sinisters in turn
would ultimately allow them to focus all
their efforts on the main Sinister now
one of the other things to remember that
we covered in the first video is that
you had more McTaggart that her mutant
power was that every time she died the
timeline reset and so what ended up
happening is that in order to prevent
that from happening or at least Sinister
resetting the timeline and restarting
his experiment that the original attack
of storm and her forces was capturing
the Maura McTaggart clones which
basically prevented Sinister from
resetting everything so that's why this
universe has just continued on the way
that it has as opposed to being reset
and changed somewhere along the lines
and so what this does is this
transitions to storm and her team
arriving at the death sphere now the
death sphere which kind of looks like a
death star is pretty awesome this is the
result of the work of orbis stellars
over the course of 100 years where this
guy was originally just a Sinister that
was out there that by using the
progenitors which are some pretty murky
Concepts in Marvel Marvel kind of teases
the idea that they predate the
celestials maybe they were created by
the celestials maybe they created the
celestials it's just one of those
inconsistent things that's been going on
ever since their appearance on the
Royals Comics back in the day but the
point is that with these progenitors and
the level of power that they us that in
a lot of ways orbis Solaris and the
progenitors have been working together
that what orbis Stellaris wanted to do
was use the power of the progenitors to
actually conquer the entirety of the
universe now of course this runs in
direct Defiance with the diamond-headed
Sinister who's starting on Earth
Conquering the entirety of the superhero
community and spreading himself outward
But ultimately it would all come to a
head with these guys most likely Waging
War against each other such as it is
that's actually not what's going to
happen here instead one of the things to
remember is that in the last video that
we covered that when it came to the more
mctaggarts which is to say again Moore's
ability to basically die and then reset
the timeline that what had happened is
that where the effort was made by storm
and her team to basically take all the
more mctaggarts and then remove them
from Sinister with the diamond on his
head so he couldn't reset the timeline
and then start all over again the moras
in turn were taken from storm and then
brought to orbis Stellaris by Destiny
herself who again was manipulating
everything behind in the scenes but with
orbit Solaris having the Morris at his
disposal the nature of this plan that
they have that was formed under Destiny
is really ingenious that what's actually
happened here and for those of you guys
who are familiar with Star Wars this
would be very reminiscent of battle
meditation that what had actually
happened here is that Cora who has the
ability to amplify the powers of anybody
around her had Amplified the abilities
of Destiny basically moving her
precognitive abilities to a more
fine-tuned point where she could
actually tell exactly what's going to
happen moments before it happens the
reason why this is so important is that
alongside Cable's telepathy what it does
is it allows Destiny to predict exactly
what the ships of orbis Solaris are
going to do and then to navigate through
them and to get around them so this is
why I say it's very much a battle
meditation kind of thing but this is all
important because of the fact that when
Storm's team arrives here what ends up
happening is orbis Stellaris most likely
in a state of hubris ends up seeing the
kind of rag band of storm he views it
more as a kind of Last Ride of storm in
the Brotherhood they intend to die right
prepare for ramming speed that kind of a
thing and so he sends out all of his
forces but with Destiny at their
disposal and being able to move in
between all these ships a way out is a
way in and the reason why I say that is
because the forces of storm actually end
up moving past all the vessels and then
fly into the exact Docking Bay that the
ships are using to get out of the death
sphere in the first place but once the
doors shut there's nobody there to
protect the inside of the sphere which
in a lot of ways gives storm and Air
Forces free reign but it's a really
smart maneuver here because when that
happens what we end up finding out is
that in the initial conversation between
storm and Destiny that with Mystique out
of the picture what Destiny wanted to do
was basically wipe out all the mores
right kill one or all of them reset the
timeline and take everything back to the
way it was supposed to be the fact that
her and Mystique could continue to live
some measure of a life is the only
reason she hadn't done it but the
actions of Destiny is actually what led
to the death of Storm's original
Brotherhood team in the first place so
storm does continue to hold on to a
vendetta and this comes to a head when
storm decides to betray the plan and
then orders Cora to kill Destiny on the
spot now whether or not Destiny saw this
coming or even potentially realized it
was just the end result of her fate this
is where she died and that was basically
it we don't necessarily know but what we
do know is that with Destiny killed the
rest of the team doesn't really
understand what's going on here and even
Marvel boy asked the question he's like
I don't get it we got here and then
we're not blowing up the Moors like this
is the whole reason we came on this
mission to blow up the Moors reset the
timeline and set everything back to
normal but the response of storm is that
yes this place is hell but a hell that
still supports life and thus supports
hope which seems like a nonsensical
statement right like yes we have the
opportunity to destroy all the mores and
reset the timeline but if we keep them
alive this horrible Universe continues
on and the people in it have hope that
things can get better it's like but I
mean you can make them better right now
by wiping out the timeline so I mean you
know I just wipe out the timeline like
it's one of those things that doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense so I
submit that yes storm has become a lot
more powerful but in our old age she's
also going senile and that's why she
makes the decision that she makes it's
the only way to make it make sense but
then she also starts to realize that
again inside the core of the death
sphere are the progenitors and that they
are astronomically powerful the only
reason they Ally themselves with orbus
Stellaris is because they had a mutual
goal but once the progenitors realize
that storm and her Brotherhood are here
and that they would most likely end up
destroying the combined experiment of
the progenitors and orbis Solaris they
would manifest they would step in and
then storm and Air Forces wouldn't stand
a chance and so in order to ensure that
doesn't happen and this is why I say
Storm's level of power just absolutely
skyrockets that in order to ensure that
doesn't happen that Cora under the
direction of storm amplifies Storm's
Powers even further right her ability to
control the weather is all Amplified and
then in turn storm Taps into the Magics
of her ancestors and then rips open a
black hole and when that happens it
pulls the progenitors and even the core
of the world Farm through right the
world forum is where they're basically
experimenting and all that kind of stuff
now the progenitors do end up basically
leaving and focusing on their own
individual worlds but lest we forget the
idea of storm opening up a gravity well
in space that's astronomical because
what you're now talking about here is
reality warping right she's a low-level
reality Warfare but she's manipulating
matter on the atomic level and this is
why I say when you're talking about
Omega Level mutants even storm herself
directly addressing this right to be
Omega Level means to be Without Limits
that in effect every Omega Level mutant
has a level of power that in some
capacity City allows them to manipulate
the structure of matter that's why
there's no limit to their abilities
right somebody with high level
telekinesis can manipulate matter
somebody who has low-level telekinesis
can manipulate matter they move objects
around but a person who practices that
telekinesis long enough specifically if
they're in Omega Level mutant with no
upper limit then it's only a matter of
time before moving a chair around a room
turns into moving molecules around and
restructuring matter and that's exactly
what storm just did she used her power
to manipulate weather which is in and of
itself manipulating molecules even if it
only affects weather in a localized
space and she's expanded the sound to
now controlling the atomic structure or
the molecular structure of matter within
a localized space again she's not
Franklin Richards level but the ability
to alter matter in a localized space is
massive but here's one of the beautiful
things about this or tragic if you want
to consider it that with orbis Stellaris
realizing that The Jig Is up right this
is a losing game there's no way for him
to come out on top anymore that is all
basically over that he shuts down life
support within the system itself it
basically kills everybody inside the
ship outside of storm and her forces but
with storm exerting so much power at one
time she can't survive the experience
and storm dies and so this is amazing
because literally she goes out with a
bang and so in turn her Brotherhood
seizes control of the ship of orbus
Solaris and then most likely starts
using it as a beachhead and their
continuing war against the forces of the
sinisters that are trying to manipulate
and conquer the entirety of the Marvel
Universe
what's going on Rob this is guys and we
are back with nightcrawlers so this
opens in one of the coolest ways ever
right the sons of sinister story is
phenomenal so what we end up finding out
here is that where the night crawlers
were originally introduced to us as what
were by all standards of measurement
kind of like the Assassins of the
original Mr Sinister Nathaniel Essex
that in the first video that we did we
found that over time the night crawlers
started to break away from his influence
and so what ended up happening is that
defecting from Mr Sinister they started
allying themselves with Mother righteous
who was another clone of sinister that
existed out there now by and large she
had just kind of been hands off she was
watching everything unfold the original
quiet Council so the original leaders of
the X-Men who were influenced by the
diamond sinister's power ultimately
defecting taking over from him and then
kind of launching a conquest of the
universe that one of the things that we
find is that over time while that was
happening right that when the first
video took place 10 years later this one
taking place a hundred years later that
in that 90-year window the universe has
become come a very dark place the forces
of magic who have basically again broke
away from control of sinister has been
launching a conquest and in fact tried
to bring the magical realm or the
Demonic realm of limbo into the main
Marvel Universe and didn't succeed right
that one of the things Xavier did as the
really like the villainous version of
himself he traveled to the Shia Empire
right their Homeworld and used his
telepathy to convince them that
everybody was out to get them and
basically drove the Shia empire into a
state of Civil War where they are
started killing each other why you have
the forces of Asgard which are always at
war with any other race that's out there
because it's trying to remain in
isolation that there's a point where
other world right so King Arthur and all
those guys that Empire basically starts
to crumble and fall due to no protection
coming from the X-Men or anything the
universe as a whole is quite literally
completely and totally falling apart and
it's really interesting to see that
because the X-Men went from being Heroes
to being villains that they've led to
this full-scale conquest and collapse of
reality as we know it in terms of any
real organizational structure across the
universe as a whole it's a very dark and
Bleak place but through all of that what
the night crawlers have been doing in
the service of mother righteous if
they've been kind of hopping and
skipping through these different events
and stealing particular artifacts right
stealing small little things in the
midst of this giant battle between like
Loki and the asgardians and whatever
Force happens to be out there the night
crawlers teleport in steal an artifact
and then teleport out and so what it
does is it focuses on Asgard proper that
what they're doing is they're hunting
for an artifact specifically they're
hunting for the hammer of Thor and that
when they get there Thor immediately
turns on them and then tries to attack
them but understand the night crawlers
at least Kurt Wagner by himself just a
guy is probably the most prodigious
assassin that Marvel Comics has but you
never see him operate in that way but
what ends up happening is that because
you have Laura Kinney x-23 who was
basically merged with the Nightcrawler
Gene it's effectively a version of
Wolverine who can teleport like
Nightcrawler she still has the
adamantium claws so she overcomes Thor
like that I mean in the blink of an eye
slices his arm off and that's basically
it now because they can't actively lift
his hammer what they end up doing is
they end up having one of the other
members of what are called the night can
basically and a different name for the
night crawlers that what they do is they
use their ability to manipulate gravity
to control where the hammer goes now
that's not uncommon and in fact that's
been a thing in Marvel Comics for years
ever since Magneto first Fought The
Avengers we've seen people who have been
able to use the fundamental properties
of the electromagnetic spectrum or
gravity or what have you to manipulate
the hammer of Thor but what we end up
doing is transitioning over to Vox ignis
who again is basically uh Sean Cassidy
Banshee with the power of kind of a
Ghost Rider basically by all standards
the measurement it has a different name
and a history but it is in effect one of
the Ghost Rider spirits that ended up
becoming a good guy but the important
thing here is that it is Banshee within
immense level of power but he doesn't
really do a whole lot here so it's not
overly important to understand his
character what he does do is he goes and
he talks to Laura Kenny and what she
says is that her former husband
basically is undergoing What's called
the last right right that's summer night
which is what he's called she says he's
losing his battle against the diamond
Sinister is retaking control a great
trauma can have that effect now here's
why that matters because one of the
things we learned is that when Sinister
created the night crawlers that he
intentionally bred infertility into them
meaning that they cannot procreate or
they should not be able to but much like
the dinosaurs from Jurassic Park life
finds a way and what ended up happening
is Laura Kinney x-23 and the
Nightcrawler Cyclops ended up having a
baby the problem is the baby suddenly
teleported out right it literally just
disappeared seemingly out of nowhere and
what it looked like is that its powers
manifested at Birth and teleported away
but the kicker to this is that while
Laura seemed to be able to get past it
or at the very least was kind of like
you know I've endured pain and torment
and Trauma before that Nightcrawler
Cyclops was not able to do the same and
has effectively just become a drunk
right his pain in losing his child has
just gotten the worst of it and so the
result of this is he undertakes what's
called the last right in the sense that
it's ritualistic suicide and what
happens is that he literally teleports
to essentially the force field that
surrounds all the more mctaggarts and
the hopes that like his sacrifice will
bring the force field down now that's
something that I want you to keep in the
back of your head one because we're kind
of doing this in segments right so
instead of doing an issue by issue and
Order we're doing the night crawlers
then Immortal X-Men or immoral X-Men and
so on and so forth so based on the
videos we've run it might be a smidge
out of order here but that whole
ritualistic sacrifice is something that
I want you to keep in mind because one
of the things that happens is that Sean
Cassidy and having this conversation
with Laura Kinney she starts asking
these questions right she says we're
running low on the Flesh of Cortez to
extend our leaps because people who are
familiar with the X-Men know Fabian
Cortez is a mutant that has the ability
to amplify the powers of mutants around
him and so with the inability to clone
mutants the same way uh Sinister was
that the ability to use the the
abilities of Fabian Cortez are running
low so they won't be able to teleport as
far as as long as things stay on this
current course the other part of that is
that without the ability to procreate
and with the nightcrawlers teleporting
in ritualistic suicide due to this last
right basically the ending of their
lives their numbers are running low in
essence the night crawlers are basically
going extinct and so if for no other
reason for self-preservation you have
Laura Kinney who says you need to go ask
a question to Mother righteous in order
for us to get a definitive answer and
what Sean Cassidy says and this is
something that's really important too is
he says he does talk to Mother righteous
but she always approaches people and
always asks the same question if you
could do things over what would you have
done differently now one of the
instances where she asked this question
is to Legion now remember a legion is an
Omega Level mutant I mean this guy's got
thousands of personalities each one with
a power of its own but he also has the
ability to alter reality now within the
Legion of X comic books where the mother
righteous was initially introduced one
of the things that Legion had done is he
had basically created a pocket Universe
where he could bring the spiritual
essence of different mutants in and they
could live a life or live some measure
of escape from the reality of the world
that they lived in what he's done here
is that continuing this dimensional
realm this pocket Universe he created
that he literally brought the X-Men that
he could save to this place so they left
their physical bodies behind and their
spiritual Essence remains here but it
seems to kind of be the larger part of
Legion himself he kind of absorb them
into himself and as he's talking to
Mother righteous what he effectively
says is if I could do it all over again
I never would have trusted you I never
would have believed you I never would
have let you get your clutches and
introduced you to the X-Men the way that
I did such as it is there's only one
thing that I can do and it's to Simply
leave to a higher plane of existence now
the crazy thing about this is that where
x23 is hearing a story she initially
sees the original Legion as a person
that could save them and he could given
the level of power that he has at his
disposal he could fix everything in an
instant but he's become disillusioned
with the entirety of not just the mutant
population but the universe as a whole
why save a place that you believe simply
just deserves to die that you don't care
about anymore and so he ultimately takes
off we don't know where he goes to and
we ultimately never find out the
important thing here is that x-23 has
Sean Cassidy talked to Mother righteous
for the purpose of allowing the
nightcrawlers to go on a mission and
what they end up doing is they basically
teleport back to Earth which is now just
become this really dark and crappy place
that's just been run amok with all the
experiments of sinister that are
constantly evolving and constantly
changing albeit without any real measure
of sentience of their own and they in
turn get to the Xavier Institute right
the the place where the X-Men used to
reside and they find Dr Nemesis there
now Dr Nemesis under normal
circumstances right James Bradley he's
just a guy that has an incredible level
of intelligence but due to the
experimentation of sinister over time
he's basically kind of infused with what
is an effect fungal matter and what this
has done is allowed him to expand this
fungal matter across the entirety of the
world and is also expanded his
intelligence to go along with it so he's
like this just astronomically genius
being more so than he ever was before
but the reason for the X-Men being there
at least the night crawlers being there
is because once they teleport back the
kind of situation they present to Mother
righteous is that using the intelligence
of Dr Nemesis they can find some way to
start cloning more nightcrawlers and
continue the propagation and the
existence of their race now something to
understand here is x-23 making this
declaration and presenting this entire
scenario to Mother righteous it was
effectively a ruse she basically won on
the mission with ulterior motives there
was the public motive she gave which is
we need to find a way so that the night
crawlers can continue to exist so we can
continue serving you right you know in
an honorable fashion as our religious
leader and so on and so forth the
reality here is she teleported down to
earth so she could grab the original
Nightcrawler who's long since been
mutated and has just kind of run its
evolutionary course so that he can show
up here and kill mother righteous and
the reason why is because what mother
righteous does from a religious
perspective and we'll talk more about
this here in a second because I feel
like the religious motivations of her
character are a lot more clear in the
third issue than the second issue but
when she kind of pitched herself is this
religious leader she kept talking about
the spark right the spark of the of of
the mutant population and so on and so
forth but the reason why I say this is
that the spark as it was originally
introduced in Marvel Comics was a
concept by Nightcrawler that was a
colloquial term for Faith right keep the
spark alive keep the faith alive right
keep the belief alive that kind of a
thing right it was kind of a way to say
like we're the ones who keep the faith
strong we're the heroes we do the good
thing that kind of a situation what
mother Rogers has done here is corrupted
and basically use it for her own ends
the spark is you doing whatever it is
that I tell you to do because I'm your
religious leader that's basically what
she's done and so when the original
Nightcrawler shows up here he's angry at
her because of the fact that she has
basically perverted what the spark is
supposed to represent but mother
righteous in no uncertain terms kills
this guy on the spot right literally
wipes him out and he's referred to as
the apostate right the guy who defied
the the will of mother righteous tried
to kill the religious leader and so with
the death of Nightcrawler x-23 tries to
jump in and then in turn mother
righteous snaps her fingers and then
submits x-23 to just an astronomical
amount of mental pain but that turns out
to be the nail in the coffin for mother
righteous and it happens in two
different ways the first is because she
tells the other night kin to basically
wrap up the apostate and then send him
toward his own Doom right to experience
the last right which is basically
teleporting him into the force field
surrounding the mor May Taggarts and the
hopes that they can basically break
through the other reason why this is a
big deal is because in the moment when
x23 is being tortured by mother
righteous what happens is she gets a
glimpse of the daughter that she
believed to have been dead only to find
out that mother righteous is actually
holding her prisoner but we also get
this insane moment right because with
issue number three we jump forward a
thousand years and what we end up
finding out here is somewhere along the
line and we don't know how this happened
and we're not given any explanation as
to how it happened Absalon Mercator had
basically merged or somehow become a a
combination person with the Silver
Surfer now the Silver Surfer most all of
you guys know who that is but Mr M is an
Omega Level mutant with the power to
warp reality so it would be like if
Franklin Richards in the Silver Surfer
merged right just a crazy level of power
so much so that what the ad what the the
silver Mercator was doing was traveling
around the universe and unstitching the
lokies from reality literally wiping
them from existence removing them from
the universe now this has happened in a
variety of ways and among a variety of
different people different sinisters
were overcome by The Brood horde which
are basically the Marvel Comics version
of the aliens right the xenomorph movie
that kind of thing Sigourney Weaver and
all that it's their version of that more
or less right the two kind of run hand
in hand but mother righteous herself
still continues on with this idea of
trying to find a way to attain What's
called the reliquary perilous as well as
breaking through the force field of the
more mctaggarts now this is where all
the stuff we've been talking about
starts to get cleared up so mother
righteous with regard regards to her
religious convictions positions herself
as the religious leader of the
nightcrawlers but the reality is she
doesn't care anything about them she
sees them as a means to an end but what
she'd learned over the course of her
time is nothing will convince people to
do something like religious Faith right
it's like that line from The Book of Eli
when Gary oldman's character is talking
about the nature of the nature of the
Bible and he says it's a tool to control
the weak and the desperate and that's
how mother righteous uses religion here
that you have all these nightcrawlers
who have just have these grotesque
physical appearances because without the
ability to clone the original
Nightcrawler they're making clones out
of clones out of clones right so you
have Laura Kinney who is a clone of
Nightcrawler or kind of a chimera of
Nightcrawler they clone Laura Kinney
which has her own set of problems but
they clone that clone and they cloned
that clone so on and so forth so you run
into this situation where you have these
grotesque and mutated versions of
Nightcrawler but it doesn't matter to
her because the only real purpose they
serve is to basically commit ritualistic
suicide that whenever one of them show
up here and they say mother I have to
apologize I've heard Talk of the
apostate and like the false prophet
right so Nightcrawler the original
Nightcrawler that tried to kill mother
righteous and the false prophet
basically x-23 who tried to kill mother
righteous that whenever they hear talk
about this and they tell mother
righteous about that in order to remove
anybody that may even begin to Harbor
the idea that she's not telling the
truth she basically uses the religious
conviction through words and saying it's
okay my child take the last right and
you will be forgiven of your sins and
they teleport themselves to Suicide it's
pretty dark man it's really really dark
it's a horrible thing to do and what's
so crazy about this is again she doesn't
believe anything she's saying she's
doing it one part because it gains her
power and two just because she can right
she's doing it for no other reason than
the fact that she can and it basically
creates willful servants that are just
too naive to ask any questions of her
right by seeding out and removing any
measure of dissent that now she has this
almost kind of group of people that
follow her with with no pun intended a
religious fervor and so in the midst of
this conversation or where she sends
this this Nightcrawler off to die again
she has what's called a Phoenix egg
which can potentially Harbor allow for
the birth of a phoenix you know the
Phoenix returning to a particular house
again this all kind of goes into the
reliquary perilous so you're not going
to see anything crazy which we will
explain what the perilous is but she's
talked to by Dr Nemesis who has long
since left Earth but become this giant
fungal organism but what he's done is
he's taken his ability to control fungal
organisms and now he's able to see and
hear everything Across the Universe and
what he tells her is that the original
Mr Sinister has basically resurfaced now
we know this just by virtue of the
events that have transpired in the
immoral X-Men comic which is really
really cool if you guys haven't seen our
video on that you'll find a link to it
down in the comments section but what
mother righteous says here is that she's
largely been hands off she's been
focusing on her own little scheme over
here and the diamond X-Men and all the
other X-Men out there have been Waging
War against each other trying to conquer
the the universe and so on and so forth
and she started to realize there's a
much bigger event at play here and it
all comes down to Destiny now that's
been a common theme that we've talked
about in the sins of sinister story The
Destiny is a precognitive she can see
the future if she tells you something's
gonna happen in 500 years take it with a
grain of salt if she tells you
something's gonna happen in five minutes
take it as an absolute truth and so she
kind of touches on some of the events
that have transpired over time that
Mystique ultimately ended up dying that
the entire motivation behind Destiny
doing everything she did in this
universe was to try to find some measure
of a life with Mystique but the reality
here is that because Mystique felt like
like she was caged it was only a matter
of time before she went out to fight the
oppressors and was ultimately killed but
with the death of Mystique her being the
wife of Destiny the response of Destiny
is then we simply reset the timeline and
that's basically it right now that my
love interest is gone and there's
nothing here for me anymore now we do
the right thing we set the universe back
to the way that it's supposed to be by
killing one of the mara clones but of
course as we know from the storm and the
Brotherhood of mutant storyline she was
killed right she was literally cut in
half at the direction of storm herself
right this desire to keep this universe
going to keep this universe alive and so
what ends up happening here is Mother
righteous is told by Dr Nemesis there is
an object that is heading towards the
more metagrance right this in this
impenetrable force field that nobody
seems to be able to access and when
mother righteous realizes what it is she
realizes this was set in motion by
Destiny thousands of years ago like a
thousand years ago when the sins of
sinister story first kicked off and so
what she does is she brings together all
the night crawlers she has she has the
trumpet sounded they all teleport into
the impenetrable force field and they're
all killed right they're all eradicated
and so the only other thing that she
does is she basically brings in what's
called Auntie Fortune now Auntie Fortune
was at the beginning of simsa sinister a
Nightcrawler that had been merged with
Domino and as those of you guys who are
familiar with Domino from Marvel Comics
know she has the ability to Bend luck in
her favor and this is the reason why
mother righteous always has the brain of
Auntie Fortune around her because no
matter what happens things will always
happen to fall in her in inner favor
luck will always be on her side and her
being here is no different because what
happens is that in watching all of this
transpire you suddenly have a Ghost
Rider imbued Galactus who arrives on the
scene and it's amazing to see because
when that happens right Banshee shows up
and says like Yes somewhere along the
line we don't know how it happened and
honestly we never find out how it
happened all the different spirits of
Vengeance that had escaped Earth at the
rise of the forces of sinister bonded
themselves to Galactus now all of this
seems to be predicated on the fact that
Galactus being a being of hunger was
Hunger for vengeance against the mutant
population for everything they had done
to the universe but whatever the
motivation is it's a being traveling
around the universe with the powers of
the Ghost Rider wiping out everything in
his path and so where you do have Sean
Cassidy that says we have to step in and
do something the response of mother
righteous is no she says a thousand
years ago the sinisters shot an
Unstoppable object right through the
brain of a Titan they didn't stop to
wonder where it would go next but
Destiny did Destiny knew now if you guys
remember at the very beginnings of the
sins of sinister's story the first one
shot that we got that you had the island
of krakowa that literally had a giant
tree that could the the mutant
population could talk to what ended up
happening is that in an effort to
lobotomize the krakowan island and take
away its control allowing the X-Men free
reign to operate as they wanted to under
the influence of sinister they shot the
Juggernaut through its head and what she
says is a millennium of gravity Wells
slingshots infinitesimal changes of
course building speed becoming light and
time screaming in the Silence of the
vacuum unable to die unable to stop
madder than a box of otters while she
tweaked the path of the world Farm
setting up a cosmic trick shot and
impossible conjunction enter the
Juggernaut and the Juggernaut smashes
through the head of Galactus like bam
now this is the cool thing about this
Destiny said all this in motion she said
everything in motion and this is why I
say this is why Destiny is such a cool
character because a thousand years ago
Destiny looked at what was going to
happen in the future and said okay the
X-Men are most likely gonna do this this
is most likely what's gonna happen
that's most likely what's gonna happen
so in order to ensure everything
transpires the way it's supposed to I
will do this this this this and this and
move these pieces around in this way so
that at the right time the Juggernaut as
he was shot into space by the X-Men what
ultimately smash through the head of
Galactus and in doing so puncture a hole
through the impenetrable force field of
the moramctaggarts right the right place
at the right time that's how capable of
a precognitive Destiny is and so the
result of this is that with the more
mittaggart force field basically being
blown wide open it allows mother
righteous to enter with the reliquary
perilous now here's the funny thing
about the reliquary perilous that the
way she pitched it to the night crawlers
the way she builded to the night
crawlers it's an artifact of
unimaginable Powers the thing in which
we worship and it's a thing that we
value that's never what it was she was
using it as a tool against the night
crawlers in order to gain their faithful
service the nature of the reliquary
perilous is that it's a time capsule
that when she went around and she was
asking all these people if you could
change anything what would you change
she would take their answers and she
would confine it in the reliquary
perilous she knows it's only a matter of
time between before somebody resets the
entirety of the universe by killing one
of the moirers remember the power of
Maura mctaggard is every time she dies
the universe resets now the goal of
mother righteous was to grab all these
different artifacts all these different
bits of power how these different things
work where to gain these little pieces
of power right to even take things like
the Phoenix egg and so on confine it
into what's basically a time capsule and
send it back through the time stream and
then kill one of the moiras herself and
reset reality so that when the time came
because mother righteous is a clone of
sinister and because she was around 200
years before the events of sins of
sinister ever took place that what she
would be able to do is she could send
the artifact to herself and then she
would gain an astronomical amount of
power and she'd be able to basically
conquer existence she could make the
universe whatever she wanted it to be
using the power of the Phoenix egg so on
and so forth making herself a host for
the Phoenix force with the power of Thor
all that kind of cool stuff but of
course what ends up happening here is
that with Banshee realizing the goal of
mother righteous was never to try to
find a way to preserve the entirety of
this universe but to actually kidnap the
child of x-23 so it can be used for
really even raise for a mother righteous
own ends in the distant past to
basically send all that back and
effectively Wipe Out the universe that
Banshee has the same motivation that
storm did in storm of the Brotherhood
where she basically made this argument
in saying that yes this universe is
awful but those who are native to this
universe who were born into this
universe they all have the right to try
to find the best possible life they can
and that by wiping this universe out
we're taking that away from them we're
dooming countless billions or trillions
of people and so in that moment he tries
to attack mother righteous now when that
happens she strips some of his power and
with him basically being powerless
that's when x23 jumps in with the
intention of attacking mother righteous
now she is able to hear hit her
momentarily but of course using her own
power mother righteous is able to
overcome x23 but in that moment Shaun
Cassidy looking to atone for all of his
actions over the course of sins of
sinister ends up stabbing mother
righteous as a distraction and once that
distraction comes in Acts 23 stabs
mother righteous to the test with her
tail and kills her on the spot and so
when it's all said and done basically
Laura gets her daughter and then
teleports away right she gets her child
and just takes off and that's basically
it banshees just kind of left there
dying into kind of atone for his actions
the reliquary perilous is just sitting
there on the ground and ultimately what
ends up happening is the true Mora
McTaggart arrives and seizes it for
herself all indications being she's
gonna do exactly what mother righteous
did which is find a way to send the
heart back to herself kill herself reset
the timeline and then attain absolute
power because lest we forget one of the
things we learn in Jonathan Hickman's
run on the X-Men in Inferno is that in
order to save the mutant population the
goal of Maura McTaggart was to eliminate
all the mutant powers and the mutant
Gene itself while preserving the lives
of anybody who was a mutant in effect
making every mutant human whether that
works or not we don't fully know
what's going on guys this is Rob we are
back with sins of sinister the
conclusion so let's get into it because
I'm excited to see how you feel about
the ending because every comic book fan
everywhere is theorizing what the ending
means which I'm really excited to see
what you guys think but what this does
this initially picks up with storm and
the Brotherhood of Newton's with a third
issue now remember the third issue of
storm and the Brotherhood picks up 900
years after the death of storm which he
had that momentary moment where she just
went like beyond omega level and then
died and so what this means is that John
iron fire kind of the second in command
of storm is now the one running the show
now remember his main power is that he
can turn his blood into metal which will
really become important later on down
the line but the other part of this is
that this is all drawn the attention of
Emma Frost now A Thousand Years in the
future Emma Frost has seemingly merged
herself with what she calls the red
diamond but more or less seems to be a
portion of the Crimson Gem of sidorak
now there's nothing to indicate that she
is a Harbinger which is to say a version
of the Juggernaut but the fact remains
she is nigh indestructible in this form
and so what she's been doing or what she
is doing at the moment is scouring the
space ways looking for sinister because
previously she thought he was dead but
when she found out he was alive she
realized it's only a matter of time
before he gets his hands on one of the
moras downloads everything that had
happened or takes all the information of
the last 1 000 years puts it into Amora
and then kills her because remember the
nature of Maura mctagrid's power is that
every time she dies the timeline resets
but she remembers everything that
happened over the course of her life so
that's kind of the goal the Sinister has
it's a giant experiment right it's
literally all it is now what we end up
doing here is we pick up with Sinister
directly basically at the headquarters
of the Brotherhood because remember
where the Brotherhood is located they
guard all the Clones of Mora so that's
been where sinister's been trying to get
to the entire time now the other thing
about this is that if you guys recall in
the early days of the X-Men Comics one
of the things we learned is we had what
were called the five basically whenever
the X-Men want to resurrect somebody
from the dead they need five particular
mutants in order to do it what we end up
finding out here is that the mutants
that Resurrect The Dead are basically
different now A Thousand Years in the
future than they were in the past but
the process Still Remains they can
resurrect people all they needed was the
ability to pull it off kind of a
resurrection egg of sorts and Sinister
presents the Brotherhood with that and
they do exactly what you would expect
them to do which is resurrect storm but
there's a caveat to this right it's one
of the coolest things about it as a
caveat because when I saw this my
thought was okay so like storm coming
back I kind of get where they're coming
from right death doesn't mean the same
anymore storm does return but remember
the second part of the Resurrection
process when it came to the X-Men is
they would always back up the memories
of the various mutants who died so when
they were resurrected Jean Gray or Hope
Summers or whoever they were using would
telepathically put those memories in
their head there's no one here to do
that so yes storm is back but storm does
not remember the full totality of her
powers she doesn't remember how she died
she doesn't remember anything about her
past life so she's basically brand new
to the world now it's kind of a funny
thing here because as this happens Emma
Frost makes her move and sends all of
her forces directly to the Citadel of
the Brotherhood and again Chimera is the
name of the game merging different
mutant Powers into a singular mutant and
that's why you have like super strong
versions of Cyclops that are gigantic in
size that can fire massive energy beams
and they're just ridiculously strong all
that kinds of stuff and so the reality
here is the forces of Emma are Next
Level because not only that Emma Frost
actually allows herself to be placed
inside of what is an effect a giant
Diamond robot right like she's colossal
in size so then she launches her attack
and because of her telepathy combined
with her indestructible form she
basically just starts crushing everybody
at the Citadel now it's a really cool
moment when this happened so the reason
why is because John iron fire leads the
attack against Emma Frost's forces but
then at that moment because a doombot
had survived or we covered that in the
last video that we did that Sinister
rips off the hands of one of the Doom
bots which as you guys know basically
have like these little lasers that can
shoot out of them by all standard is a
measurement he effectively has a gun and
so when this happens storm basically
uses their powers or uses the kind of
intuition that comes with what you could
call the knowledge of her powers Taps
into what she's capable of and then
launches an attack against Emma Frost
now for the most part she's relatively
successful this is also because of the
fact that Korra who has the ability to
amplify the powers of other people
boosts the powers of storm we saw that
in the second issue of storm in the
Brotherhood which is how storm became
beyond omega level in the first place
the same thing happens here but the
difference is that instead of storm
using magic like she did in the second
issue what she does is it shows shows a
pure display of what she's capable of
now this is a huge moment right it's
very easy to forget and it's very easy
to lose focus of how significant this is
but what storm does is she uses her
power over the lightning to control the
electrons within the structure of Emma
Frost this giant robotic body and then
detonates the whole thing in what's
basically a nuclear explosion now it
does kill storm but the big moment
behind this and the reason why this is
so important is because it shows that
storm can control the electrons of any
object around her due to her ability to
tap into lightning now this is
comparable to like Jubilee from the
X-Men there are those of you guys who
don't know what I'm talking about
there's a comic where Emma Frost I if I
remember correctly was Emma Frost had
seized control of Jubilee and then
realized when she makes those little
firework type things that she's actually
detonating matter and that if Jubilee's
power were pushed to his absolute limits
she could quite literally detonate
matter on the subatomic level and just
create nuclear explosion out of nowhere
she could blow up a whole world if she
wanted to or even make a star go
supernova we haven't really seen
anything to indicate that she's getting
to that point but that's the potential
of what she has storm is very much in
that way this is an instance where
Marvel is teasing what storms capable of
and we may very well see that at some
future point in time but of course storm
basically perishes so she was here just
kind of for a moment long enough to
defeat Emma Frost but in this momentary
distraction Sinister uses the gun from
the Doctor Doom doombot and then fires
it at John iron fire and shoots him in
the head and so with John ironfire out
of the picture seemingly the entire
landscape is clear right Emma Frost is
defeated her forces will launch a
counter-attack but the reality is
they're not overly concerned about it
what Sinister is concerned about is that
with Emma Frost defeated someone's going
to step up and take her place and when
they do they're going to come after the
attacker clones as well so in
reality they're they're really on a kind
of timeline here the other thing that
complicates the this is access to where
the Clones are located is blocked and
there's seemingly no way to get to it
now one of the funny things about this
is Sinister talks about in the message
that was left to him by Destiny that
there was a kind of indication that
Destiny had set in motion a set of
events that would allow Sinister to gain
access to the clones by quite literally
destroying the door this coincides with
the moment that we covered in the last
video when we ended up finding out that
in the early days when Sinister was
basically taking over everything when
the X-Men were coming under semester's
control that they fired Juggernaut into
space literally out of a cannon in order
to destroy Thanos because remember once
the Juggernaut starts moving nothing can
stop him and being fired at Thanos like
a gun would blow a hole right through
him and that's exactly what it did right
it killed Thanos on the spot but what
this also did is it just sent Juggernaut
careening through space speeding up
going faster and faster right just
slingshotting off of stars and different
things like that the this is what we
talked about in the last video it's
Destiny playing the long game as a
precognitive she can see the future and
so even though a thousand year
prediction isn't the most solid
prediction when it comes to Destiny
every so often it is exactly right right
literally the Juggernaut comes flying
through punches Galactus in the head who
had shown up here being possessed by all
the powers of the Ghost Rider again we
covered that in the last video make sure
you guys check the comments you'll find
a link to the Sims of sinister playlist
you can get caught up on everything and
then in turn like punches a hole
directly through the door where they
where the mores are being located that
gives them the interest now the other
version the girl that you see here in
like the white outfit with the blonde
hair that is Amore mctagrid but it's a
robot right it's not an actual Morris so
she doesn't have an X Gene right so if
you were to kill her nothing would
happen here but the thing about this is
that we end up finding out that John
iron fire actually survived and the
reason why what he did here and it's
probably the most comic book logic thing
ever right the biggest MacGuffin ever
because he has the ability to turn his
blood into metal that before going into
a battle which is a pretty smart thing
he does exactly that he just like
protected his inner working so you
basically have like flesh and Bone veins
all that kind of stuff and then now his
blood is basically metal it was a layer
of protection against the shot the
Sinister fired so that's how John iron
fire lived here and so what kind of
fight breaks out between the two of them
but it's basically just buying time for
more McTaggart to get in there the
problem is that while more McTaggart is
supposed to gain access to all the other
moral clones she's supposed to clear the
way if there's any resistance for
Sinister the problem with this is that
her immediate response is I need to
destroy these clones but Sinister wants
to take the information he has
downloaded into the Clones so that when
one of them dies the timeline resets and
all the way back at the very beginning
at year zero before everything happens
Sinister can extract the information and
then basically know where he went wrong
so when he repeats his experiment trying
to take over the entirety of the
universe he knows where he missteps and
he can correct those Stakes the problem
with this is that in the absence of Emma
Frost Hank McCoy Beast who is basically
assumed control of her forces contacts
Charles Xavier but Xavier also being in
control here right being just a Villain
at this point in time starts to realize
it's a chance for opportunity so he sees
his control of Hank McCoy seizes control
of everybody in just like this immediate
area and then quite literally makes a
planet unto himself Professor Xavier of
the X-Men becomes a whole world and then
he just starts traveling directly to the
Citadel where more mctaggard and all
those different clones are being held
now once you have Jon and them who
realize what's going on John ironfire
has this genius idea right he literally
conjures this energy dagger and then
slices his forehead right and what he
does is as the blood comes out he
controls it and turns it into a helmet
of Magneto which basically blocks the
telepathic abilities of Charles Xavier
it's one of the smartest moves that I've
seen from his character like I mean it's
not to say he's dumb but it's a genius
idea and so what ends up happening here
is that Sinister kind of pleads with
John iron fire and saying look I get
that you guys as part of the Brotherhood
all that kind of stuff your soldiers
Warriors and having an honorable death
is the way you want to go and so on and
so forth but you don't really want to
die here more so than that you do not
want Xavier to kill all of us kill one
of the moiras reset the timeline and
then he's in control right so we have to
find a way to defeat Xavier and only you
can do it but you need more power and
because blood is literally the source of
your power I can inject you with a
sample of Iceman which will basically
allow you to amplify your abilities by
producing more water vapor blood is 70
percent water so you can basically
create more blood is it comic book logic
absolutely like I mean there's nothing
about this this logical or reasonable
like it's just a thing that's being done
for the purpose of telling the story but
it's amazing because literally this guy
just like uses this injection Khan
measures on like just this insane kind
of like structure right this metal form
he looks like a devil version of Magneto
he looks like a beast and then he just
charges at Xavier right like the whole
planet of Xavier and he's able to kind
of punch a hole through him to a degree
but in reality it's just a giant fight
between the two so while John iron fire
and Xavier are fighting that Sinister
takes off to the to the Clone lab and
then tries to find a way to stop this
robot version of Maura McTaggart but the
reality here is he kind of strikes a
deal with her and says look this is like
if if I don't do this right like if I do
not take this information on what I've
learned and download it into one of the
Morris then what will happen is history
will repeat itself I'll make the same
mistakes the same screw-ups and this
will just be a giant 1 000 year time
Loop over and over and over again if I
download this information it'll be a way
to break the cycle and I will literally
tell myself do not pursue this godhood
do not do that and so ultimately this
robot odd version of Moira lets him get
away with it and so in turn he basically
goes in and tries to destroy one of
these Mormon Taggarts but in the process
of it as he's downloading this
information he starts to come to this
Revelation maybe he can be God right
maybe he can be just like some
astronomically powerful person but in
shutting down like and destroying one of
these Morris it basically wipes out the
Galaxy and everybody in it right it
wipes out the whole universe it doesn't
really blink the timeline out of
existence and here's the reason why
because of the fact the timeline doesn't
go away this is basically Marvel telling
us this is now an alternate reality the
fact that this has happened means it
always will happen right like this is
always going to take place Sinister can
try to change it and maybe he will but
the fact that all of this has happened
before and the fact that he's even
sending information back into the past
to prevent it from taking place it means
this universe has to happen now the
funny thing about this is that in this
moment Sinister himself seems to kind of
transcend and he actually takes off and
tried to tries to form a kind of
dominion right literally basically sees
control of time and space but what he
finds out when he gets there when he
kind of transcends is that somebody beat
him to the punch that seemingly a
Sinister Dominion has already been
created one of the other sinisters
transcended time and space they exist
Beyond everything and so even if there
is an attempt by Sinister to kill one of
the Mars and reset the timeline that
there is seemingly a Sinister out there
that has already seized control of
everything and everything is happening
in the universe is now happening because
of their whim that's the implication
there's nothing to say that that's the
case it's sinister's hypothesis is what
he believed happened but at the end of
the day we don't necessarily know for
sure and so here's the kicker to this
right like when Sinister comes back he
realizes somebody did beat him to the
punch there's seemingly no way to fix
everything John iron fire reappears
after having presumably killed Xavier
pissed off of the fact that Sinister
basically wiped out the entirety of all
life Across the Universe John ironfire
kills Sinister on the spot thought and
then we jump back right like literally
we jump back to year zero right now
exactly how this jump back to year zero
happens not entirely sure it could just
be a cascading effect it could be that
like the destruction of all life across
the across the universe is kind of the
first stage in what is an effect the
reset of the timeline the reason I say
that is that in previous instances in
the X-Men comics in Marvel we never
really saw how the process takes place
Emma Frost dies and then you just jump
back to the very beginning of everything
right we don't actually see how that
process unfolds so this may just be part
of the whole thing but of course jumping
back to year zero right the moment in
which Sinister decides to make the
decision to start putting his own gene
into the various X-Men as they're being
resurrected in order to seize control
that as he's scanning one of the myras
he finds a thousand years worth of
information stored inside of her and so
when he downloads the information
everything blows up right everything
just goes nuts all of a sudden and you
basically have the real Amore McTaggart
who shows up here and kind of spills the
beans and that's she had seemingly died
alongside everything else and so what
this kind of implies here this is one of
the theories that's circulating out
there what this seems to imply is that
the the white suit and Maura McTaggart
was not actually a robot it was the real
Amora McTaggart the entire time because
remember she's Immortal you can kill her
through any conventional means but
she'll never die of natural causes
she'll stay youthful forever so that
seems to be who this actually was so
when she in effect actually reset the
timeline that gets us to where we are
right now but the kicker about all this
is more McTaggart basically tells
Sinister everything that was going on
that when you had mother righteous write
an alternate version of sinister or kind
of a different version of sinister in
the future who was trying to find a way
to download information and then reset
the timeline so she could be in control
all that stuff that everything popped
off there but the reality of what she
says here is that she watched a Sinister
had basically tried to achieve godhood
and then in turn came to a profound
realization that somebody had beat him
to the punch and the information that
was sent back to the past was
exclusively that there's no Grand amount
of information that shows the mistakes
he made how he could have created things
differently where he could have fixed
everything that's not the case right
it's just the information that
ultimately somebody beat him there he
never gets to attain godhood the way
that he hoped he had and so what Maura
McTaggart does is she wipes out all the
Clones of herself now the X Gene was
neutralized so basically the Clones are
destroyed but there's no X Gene to reset
the timeline so it's just like killing
mannequins effectively and so with all
that being done suddenly Rasputin 4
appears out of nowhere right now
Rasputin 4 was basically a creation of
sinister in the sins of sinister future
right like in that timeline and so she
was initially his ally but then once she
realized he wanted to wipe out the whole
universe and kind of reset everything
she turned against him her arriving here
is basically an instance of a character
from an alternate reality appearing in
the main Marvel Universe I told you this
would probably happen they would
probably totally end up bringing people
from alternate realities or from the
sins of sinister timeline into the main
Marvel Universe and it's cool for what
it is right but what this also shows
here is that mother righteous this
alternate clone of sinister is still
alive and well right I mean she hasn't
become the mother righteous who's
villainous and sins of sinister and all
that kind of stuff she's still alive and
doing her thing right all those
different clones of sinister are still
there the the theory that's circulating
around out here is that the version of
sinister that achieves godhood right
Dominion hood is actually mother
righteous because there's like this
whole wing of a library that just kind
of appears out of nowhere right like
basically altering reality exclusively
for mother righteous and in fact all the
books basically seem to be dedicated to
her it's like this future version of her
who would achieve godhood kind of
reaching out and saying I'm doing this
for you right this is who you become one
day again that's just the theory that's
circulating around we don't definitively
know but what we do know is that
following her capture of sinister
Rasputin basically shows up here and
effectively meets Kitty pry and the
other members of The Quiet Council now
what ends up happening is that she kind
of spills the beams to what's going on
but also presents mother righteous as
the person that was quote unquote the
Savior right the one that basically
saved everybody saved the future of the
whole nine yards now mother righteous is
manipulative exactly how this transpires
we don't know right because as far as
we're aware mother righteous as she
exists now in the X-Men Comics has no
knowledge of what will happen over the
course of the next 1 000 years when you
have the whole sins of sinister timeline
unfolding we don't know right all we
really know is that she's just kind of
here and she is a clone of like the
original Sinister and she's been
operating for the last few hundred years
and that's it that's all we know about
her character but she basically puts
herself forward as a person who is kind
of the savior of existence but one of
the things that happens is that when
Rasputin 4 spills the beans on what's
going to happen over the course of the
next 1 000 years as a result of sinister
basically putting his genes inside all
the different X-Men that are being
cloned is that the X-Men come to the
realization Sinister is the greatest
threat among them now the funny thing
here is that because Sinister as he
stands now was given information about
you know from his future self about how
some version of him out there achieved
godhood he tries to tell the X-Men there
is a Sinister out there manipulating
everything there's a Sinister out there
controlling everything manipulating
everything it's not me you have to
believe me but because of his villainous
past as well as what he's supposed to be
doing over the course of the next 1 000
years and sends a Sinister none of the
X-Men believe it none of them believe
anything he's saying so they ultimately
confine him to the pit the other caveat
to this is that in order to ensure that
Sinister has not already started his
scheme they have to quote unquote purify
the X-Men Gene which means scan them and
make sure nobody is influenced by
sinister's genes but because Emma Frost
and Xavier and these guys are leaders of
the quiet Council and because they're so
powerful and in that future they're the
ones who go nuts and basically conquer
the entirety of the universe that what
they do is they voluntarily confine
themselves to the pit now this kind of
seems to be manipulation at the hands of
mother righteous to a degree and that's
the other part of this theory that
mother righteous is the one who does
achieve godhood because she's the only
one who shows up here and she's the only
one who says in order to ensure that
sinister's influence is no longer here
in the rest of the X-Men we have to
confine the choir Council you guys know
it's what's best for the for the mutant
Community she's clearing the landscape
of any threats she's clearing the
landscape of the most powerful telepaths
she's clearing the landscape of Hope
Summers who's instrumental in being able
to revive any X-Men who die which means
now that an X-Men is dead they stay dead
right there's no way to bring them back
right she's removing any threats to her
potential attempt to seize power of not
just curricula itself but even the world
as a whole because she is a straight up
villain that's kind of where everybody
is leaning to here so again because of
this realization the entrepreneur can
find the pit and seemingly this stage is
set for mother righteous to seize
control as the newest version of
sinister and ultimately basically repeat
the processes since the Sinister and
effectively come out on top but with
that being said guys let me know what
you guys think about this down in the
comments section it's a really wonky
final issue thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace